1 et on va récupérer nous notre petit
échiquier de chasse comme moi j'ai dit
en prêt en pré pré live fab que
j'espérais une nulle à detroit
j'espère une femme très bonne entre
13h01 alors là je
hais ce qui arrive période
on vient jouer aux quatre ans à détroit
je vous le dis
d35 d'accord ce
94 est magnifique ça va me gay de folie
a trouvé cinq avoir du mal à trouver ça
qui va suer on va vous dire on vers une
façon voilà car on va pas vous dire on
n'est pas complètement qu'on regarde moi
sa fab ah oui on va tous magnifiques
alors sur scène aucune surprise donc on
ne sait pas trop
donc on voit le fion e4 et à une époque
isin je ne m'y attendais vraiment pas
écossaise ou espagnol
bagnols ce que j'aurais fait pareil on
avait parié moi je referai h3 à sa place
puis on verra je vais pouvoir s'il
refait cavaliers à 5 ou pas amer frappa
kenya 5
dont call si l'on peut pas bouger pour
le moment les pièces sur le petit
échiquier les amis
on est on est obligé de rester sur cette
vue en tout cas pour le moment ça répète
ce qu'on avait vu lors de la partie
numéro un numéro un le petit requis par
ici alors fou au 7 ou b5
un bon choix mais d'abord ce qui va
faire baisser incombe au moment où pas
est ce qu'après tournant il va voir qui
a [ __ ] en c6 car il est proche de 5 la
vue le monde ouais mais va-t-il devoir
encore bâtis le devoir il faut qu'il
trouve vessie ont ils le trouvent ils le
trouvent fab il a trouvé le bessines
corps
magnifique
assez bien joué c'est bien joué de la
part du joueur norvégien
qui bon ok donc ira qui se prépare à
jouer un combi martian comme d'hab
et c'est là la question oh voilà on
réfléchit et ce que je recherche 3 est
ce que je fais c'est trois des leurs
frais il sait ce qu'il va faire là c'est
sûr qu'il savait qu'il aurait cette
position va peut-être se levait côté
magnus quand même nom
annonce qu'il répète le coût du
président oui mais bon il a dû voir la
part sa poule à
on accueille la partie de bacrot un way
est ce que si on actualise ils n'ont
toujours pas
cette fois ci
si on a le truc donc à quatre bons
pareil c'est un anti marshall comme
autrefois stage trois mêmes commentaires
donc les blancs mais ça s'apprend
bessengue un clouage
il faut le dire important importance
clouage fab donc qu'est-ce qui fait
magnus silva nous fait refouler cette
affaire b4 même jusqu'à lausanne en
danger fabien dans ce moment de la
partie et ce qu'il va voir ce pion a
prises ou est ce qui va réussir à casser
le clouage scène et peut partir un époux
est parti et là il va falloir pour
magnus où il a trouvé fou bessette il
faut montrer quand même un sur un des
six
coups de développement qui paraît
logique mais à ce niveau là on ne voit
pas ce plu genre d'erreurs pions prend
des 5 icloud toi je surprends b 5e tour
prend 1,8 c'était c'était l'idée de yann
ils sont venus avec cette préparation
fab cette nuit mais demain 2.4 mais je
n'en reviens ouais il ne sait pas il ne
s'est pas laissée laissés prendre
l'époux qui revient sur l'échiquier
peut-être un petit peu déçu la première
escarmouche
quand j'allais en fait on fait des trois
là avec les blancs
ont fait des trois on renforce le centre
et en prend développe le cavalier on
sait 3 soit on voit
gérante des trois lycées 3 ou food et de
peut-être présidentielle présidentielle
et mvs que contre comme claironne
grosse partie maxime non mais je dois
dire en fait si tu peux répéter cette
variante pourquoi pas
parce que tu es plutôt bien mais qui m'a
fait un faux demandé une pression à ton
adversaire
tu joues pour gagner bon s'il défend
comme un génie il fera nul si des fins
purement bien il joue des trois ils
jouent des trois familles et à tous les
coups pourquoi n'es tu pas assis sur ces
chaises
ou nez tu pars en salle de repos des six
pour analyser les egytiens des thés pas
mal mais non parce que jouer
aux quilles c3 possible si vous
présidentiel possible aussi des fous des
deux ans le
président est sur b4 envoyés du c3
d'empêcher cavaliers à 5 c'est ça
t'évite ça tu ne développe
là c'est en fait bon les noirs faut
vraiment excusé des coûts très utile tu
es fou des deux en fait c'est un peu
l'idée
après aussi généralement un coup comme
fou des deux tu vois etienne bacrot dans
la base de données as tu te dis tout de
suite non mais tu a son rôle à jouer qui
a aidé deux bonnes cases mon espèce
à il s'est trompé dans son fichier il
savait que c'était des deux mais ils
savaient plus quelle pièce alors qu'elle
est de ne sait pas exactement quelle
idée bon en fait on a l'habitude de voir
ce qui a valu en d2 dans les espagnoles
et italiennes etc pour aller en f1 pour
allonger 3 le fou et décalé peut-être
ouais mais ce que gère ses contenus en
c3 s'empêche pas dans le plan d'aller en
haut de g iii quoi qu'il arrive on dé
5,3 voilà donc en fait attardée dollars
dont tu te blocs d'options bon cela dit
tu te laisses le pion c'est libre mais à
mon avis à quoi sert à
ces trois fous des deux plus tôt et qui
a aidé de bons profs donc c'est pas mal
c'est une idée peut-être frêche on va
voir beaucoup logix et karelia 5 oui en
général s'en fait ce qui est ici s'il
est bien placé
de prime abord au début de la partie
est-ce que tu ne développe beaucoup
numéro 2 tu défends ton centre tout ça
mais à un moment en fait ils te gêne un
peu l'aï bloc le fou ils bloquent le
pion il bloque tout le monde donc soit
il est là pour mieux rebouché plus tard
et faire autre chose que
j'adore ça voilà ça s'est souvent et
après
en
fait c'est peut-être juste une vie
variantes qui je vais dans les années
2000 genre je sais plus mais gaspard a
fait ça contre la tonte topalov un
linares où je vois les regarder un
plaisir sadique c'est le coup le plus
joué
ou alors si vieux mais c'est plus trop
jeu de manière modérée je pense que
c'est dans les bases avec toutes les
parties jouent en ligne ah bah oui
rock à
400 et 3
et donc qu'est né devrait donc et c3 je
pense pour moi c'est le coup classique
fou des deux avait été jouée par par
baky et donc qui est née deux voilà
ouais c'est ça kasparov à l'époque
contre les co hong kong plaza
non c'est à cannes je pense oui
il ré bien échauffés
non mais s'en est ému par cette histoire
a fuck c'est ça le problème des mires of
ouais ça donc c'est un vieux coucou 80
topalov 2004 voilà donc le fameux
linares que j'avais en tête
ses proches sorte
magnus étonné un freak baky et ont joué
food et 2 tu te voyant s'attend à ce que
est ce qu'on répète le coup de baky quoi
mais ouais donc en gros en fait c'est un
ancien cookies et des deux qui est moins
joué mais qui intéresse enfin figurines
jouets bon
il a fait des belles parties dessus
est ok partie de combat a priori
aujourd'hui on va voir tu penses
ouais ben après ça peut faire nul comme
d'hab a bien sûr mais
ce que je sais parler dans ce micro
d'accord je sais pas j'ai fait ça fait
une différence ça nous apportera une
troisième nul on commet ont réussi à
faire annuler côté carl scène c'est
quand même l'objectif du jour
mais il va jouer alors après mon cahier
à 5 on s'y attend à ce que
ce qui peut faire un autre plan jardin
des
dames 17 ça existe 116 partis
adams avait joué comme ça il ya
longtemps
bondam 17 c'est une idée que j'ai pas
chez carlson il emploie des fois c'est
pour ça que j'y pense on aime bien
relever le camion des huit en fait ça
lui fait plaisir et gardent peut revenir
6 et puis s'aliter tour aussi donc si ça
se trouve à nous jouer ça bien sûr
cavaliers à 5 c'est le coût auquel on
s'attend de bazin clairement à un autre
coup qui est possible qu'à 5/6 qui a
validé cette dame 17 pour ramener le
cahier peut-être verser 5 et puis il
pourra faire fois m6 aussi pression sur
le centre c'est jouable aussi cette idée
lors
de queyries 17
bon général les blancs font ces trois
ans bien sûr sinon quand tu te prends
qualité 5 soit tu te bouffer le fou
super-14 orkla au moins voilà tout cash
voilà donc bon je peux attendre c'est
que vous l'avez des m17 qui sait de
de bacary sagna
a nommé la vue
après ce qu'il essaye de le savoir il
essaye de comprendre ce que l'autre en
tête et ce qui doit éviter un truc et en
particulier ou pas quoi pourquoi pas toi
face verte ils ont deux heures donc
autant réfléchir t'es pas obligée
d'habiter tout tempo comme comme parfois
parfois bas selon la cadence
et a déjà j'adore je vais tempo tant
qu'ils sont dans leur prépa donc ils
montent ils prennent ma crème en 30
secondes paf paf ça monte à fond
et
donc voilà une prédiction vas-y dame des
sept
tours à huit
8 ha ha on peut avoir une petite mine
sur lequel j'ai cinq sera efficace 3
serait magnifique ah bah oui non il va
pas faire des bonds à temps je suis sûr
à 100% qu'il faut pas face faut pas
jeter les blancs à la poubelle dans un
tel match benjamin en fait l'islam pour
être beau
ça pour être beau femmes
mais c'est impossible d'en qu'il fasse
est ce qu'il ya un monde où il le fait
pas
oui un monte mais c'est débile quoi est
ce que tu penses
qu'ils ont pu s'échanger dit oui ben on
refait on refait on fait deux nuls
non non et sur abbaoui vassy fondu du
fond d'elle-même
mais j'en ris ont dit ok on fait deux
nuls ils ont accordé genre pas une nulle
mais deux nuls avant la partie non mais
ouais mais pour quoi faire parce qu'en
plus les fichiers de compte rien joué
quatorze partis c'était quand même la
grande nouveauté de ce match c'est un
truc génie à ses formats donc
on ne va pas faire va tu peux le faire
une fois cette envie de faire une fois
pour se rapprocher du 40e pour voir ce
poisson qui est jessains été obligé tap
tap n'a pas lutté cinq
noms
en tutorat ça y est mal placé va
repartir que tu peux le laisser un peu
pour voir si certains
mais bon michael et fin on s'y attend
quand même
un petit su
aller vers on sûr
c'est pas magnifique un
bon mois j'attends avec à des fins
écoute
on ne peut qu'attendre avec karelia fin
c'est vraiment le coup logique mais
tours 8 ça sert à quoi en fait bon en
maths à tour au centre est libéré à
caser suite éventuellement pour notre le
fou
ouais un jour et tu
tut tut tut tut empêche un peu les d4 g6
ça peut lutter pour prendre la case à
case f5 et aussi quand tu feras fois
fuite sera d'autant plus simple de faire
des 5 pts aura plus de cinq ans air
liquide est quoi basiquement c'est ça
ce qu'on peut faire c'est 4
je sais pas je n'aurais pas pensé mais
non plus
fait les sous un tas de coups qui sont
pas forcément mauvais on y penserait pas
ça m'a vraiment l'air moche ça je me dis
que tu vas te prendre inquiet des sept
pièces et 5 ta détroit faible à la casse
des quatre hommes bah
je sais pas enfin bon je vois que l'ordi
en fait il dit rien il 00 +0 15 mai je
pense que jamais le même chiffre chez
secours
okf un certain tafer quelle idée de
faire cavalier afin de libérer ton fond
et partir vers f5 mais en vrai si tu
arrives en e3 écrites fléchées ici c'est
qu'il met le fond g7 c'est vrai que
ouais mais bon déjà il est mieux que ton
était patent des deux tu pourras
développe et ont poussé un faire d'autre
chose que d'être là et puis peut-être
essayer de faire ces trois des quatre
jours surtout s'il en g3 bonheur on est
d'accord que c'est la prépa de carlson
aussi ici oui
non mais en fait thiam scène il est
obligé de préparer
sur tout ce qui bouge sur 4,5 donc bon
l'espagnol vxl voiture principale tu
dois toute blinde et donc il fait clair
qu'il veut jouer le marshall ont pour
l'instant n'est pour rentre pas dedans
est ce que c'est parce qu'il a rien ou
qu'il se garde une occasion pour aller
vérifier moi je sais pas tu as
probablement il a rien fait quand
j'avais déjà pas une fois pas deux fois
et donc ils tentent des antilles
marshall par ci par là donc les sillages
3 une fois il s'est pris à rêver à 5
alors je ne sais pas il ya 2 il ya deux
options c'est soit calé à 5 est vraiment
fort et qu'il n'y a rien à faire contre
en pratique il a jugé je sais pas soit
soit c'est que toute façon si tu joues
normal jarre le fou bessette machin
ça va pour les noirs juste pour après un
parti ou de suite et ont peut-être pas
que t'as pas vérifié il ya des idées et
des trucs très chaud et l'a donc comme
il va réviser se dit ok pas la peine que
je fais me l'a fait kiffer donc c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'il a parfait à 3
donc en fait soit il va essayer de tous
les anti marshall possibles et
imaginables
ça peut être des quatre tout de suite ça
peut être à quatre spots ça tu peux
refaire cahier de te faire [ __ ] de tu
peux tourner autour parce que c'est des
positions qui joue comme à chaque fois
c'est pas ça va pas en force vers la
nuls
soit
pas soit quoi soit je sais pas ce qu'est
ce que c'est pas les positions quand
même qu'ils aient favorise plus personne
en quarantaine dans le type de pression
de connaissance ces espagnols je me
rappelle le plein de partie mais juste
celle qui peut être la plus marquante
roussel contrebas qui là bas ils jouent
bien mais quasiment pas question s'il
avait joué parfaitement en fait ils
jouent ils jouent ils jouent ils jouent
ils jouent très très bien quoi ouais
donc du coup est ce que c'est
et pas une idée une mauvaise idée de
de jouer exclusivement l'espagnol et qui
va pas juste se faire dépasser dans le
milieu de jeu
bah ça peut en fait c'est le risque
puisque en fait substance et une partie
qui joue l'espagnol il car ça n'est
assez fort de sucre il a gagné des
belles
donc à voir parce que je veux dire par
là c'est peut-être que niveau
préparation il va peut obtenir un petit
quelque chose avec les blancs mais ce
qu'il s'entête pas a fait une position
est juste moins fort alors qu'il
pourrait éventuellement une autre
ouverture choisir autre chose
quand on va voir un pour l'instant
[Musique]
après jour ses passions le passé pour
lui
c'est vrai aussi
alors à fille c'est pourquoi
pour éviter les trucs angers 5 surtout
se fait fourrer fidh
tapant viendra à tour
[Musique]
7-5 peut-être bon je sais pas afin
peut-être à faire tourner le 7 et que
t'es pas super heureux de se faire
toucher par des cahiers f5 ou quoi et
deuxième truc s'il fut de tablettes
rouge est cinquième
avec avait lieu 3 et survient vers des
cinq talent et clouage
qui a fait rage 6 puis j'ai six
probablement oui enfin fois de suite et
j'ai 6 alors cavaliers detroit 10 ans
suis je pense alors là tu peut le tenir
pour l'instant mais un jour tu te feras
chassé par chelsea ce
voile avons des athlètes en herbe ont en
tête dame 17 d'abord en plus d'être une
a cédé 5 parce que je sais pas le pion y
voilà enfin à voir et j'ai six à venir
bon ok truc comme ça
c'est la partie de vlad d'après ce que
je comprends car
yoyo la fine fleur
bah forcément très bien joué c'est con
magnus se prépare
bon eh ok parti comme l'a dit rien je me
fous des domiciles
vraiment très fin et s'était retrouvé
assez mal là je crois assez vite faux et
fuite et le truchement elle fameuse au
c4 maintenant mais ça change un peu par
pasteur
s'appliquer et b4 ouais tu attaques le
b5 et donc ils ubifrance fo prend ses
quatre
la partie de tourbe et 8 c3 qui avait
lieu ça tu va se passer par là bas qui
avaient j'ai 3 kg 6 d
4d dam des quatre
ans à se mettre en place vu des
5e des tours un coureur qui est des cinq
tandems
fgf 4 kf5 mais je suis un peu car on
finit par perdre broeck est
parti
par tient pourtant deux sur la ligne
après on va voir ce que nous ou ce que
nous joue le dépôt là-dessus que
c'était la can j'ai vu la partie en
direct mais vannes et évite pas bien
s'étaient vite fait dominer
est vite fait dominer
très bon
nostradamus en 2001 il savait déjà à
bayonne toujours su après que j'ai joué
sept partis qui viennent il était sûr
qu'elle aurait dû un jour en championnat
du monde
les dés étaient déjà jetés pour rui très
fin
mais marrant fait que ça suive une
partie de vladan blitz
appartiennent il a toujours su que je
vous annonce que le castor quatre chefs
cette position la veille après à reflets
de 30 secondes on est jamais remis deux
coups d'état ici
midan
freins rouges tout misé sur le coup
franc pour toi notre coutume à 2 0 c'est
pas mal enfin c'est pas l'espace de
rouge très sévère c'est n'importe quoi
l'ange
est pas bien bon très mal je peux
regarder ça tu n'es pas bien
fabrice qu'on va réussir dans notre
petit nul aujourd'hui
carton rouge ridicule on y avait rejoint
les amis au nom l'arbitré a toujours
raison voilà les arbitres heures
aza dia problème en faute dans l'autre
sens au début de l'action
non je vais te mettre à l'esprit rugby
oui mais le rugby je pensais c'est moins
développés les arbitres ils sont bien
ils expliquent ils sont sûrs du sud
ouest ouais ils sont pas mal raison oui
mais eux ils ont raison et ils ont
raison fait mais ils ont vraiment raison
pour le coup suivant
plutôt thouars quoi l'orbiteur a
toujours raison tu as quel nombre de
caves aussi un
nom mais c'est très difficile comme
métier arbitrage mais ça va très vite et
je sais très très difficile l'arbitrage
est très difficile en revanche
l'arbitrage africain est encore clients
ah bah oui
il ya le bon et le mauvais arbitres le
bon arbitre a raison c'est ça
des cadres en fait
je suis mieux cadrer ouais
donc foulée 2 juste pour vous dire
combien de partis dans la base là dessus
22 le chiffre de veille qui il ya notre
génie qui a joué sa séquence choc
qui a battu si c'est pas possible
à enghien les bains les bains en 2001
grischa
il faudra environ s'est pas amusé et on
affirmé à l'époque combien
prend baky joie d'ailleurs
bon ça suit
les préceptes de vannes là le experts
internes il a eu trois parties en
dominant là dessus cette paire du voyage
et du monde à ce trio quand même au kick
ass triant
ses 2006
après cinq super castor afrik foot en
peut-être bon voyage ou pas du tout
comme casse parfait gretsch aucun
c'était 6 4 le coup de génie j'avais
trois bombes sous le coup sur lequel n'a
pas perdu et ça suit la partie d'alain
ouais mais qu'on prescrit hors du coup
bon ça suit aussi un vide leur adams
97,1 karpov guy hellers 83
sa suite des choses quoi ces vieilles
variante
hilaire content des pauvres garde je
crois que c'est la position qu'il
voulait avoir
300 tentes très logique on va dire plus
que puisque c4 a priori mais ces quatre
là ici ça marche pas mal c'est une force
un peu les changes
donc
ok
l'idée en fait les quelques 3
j'arrive juste augmenter la pression
battus non tu me le serais tu sortais
pièce quoi
faites à des pièces sur des balles case
pas le fou en d2 qui est bien qui
empêche carré d as un talent car à lyon
1-3 qui contrôlent des 5e 5 voilà tu
passais deux pièces mineurs sur des
belles cases au final ils sont passés de
c1 des deux translation quoi à eux trois
des dons mais dans l'autre sens donc
c'est tout l'intérêt du cavaly des deux
par rapport aux cavaliers c3 qui
travaillent verger 3 et notre honneur
retrouvé là tu es venu vers 3 dans ta
famille les cavaliers en premier et
ensuite tu as sorti le fou que sita est
sorti le fouet en premier le cavalier en
b1 il aurait pas réussi à accéder à eux
trois
bon tu ne gardes les idées de ces quatre
j'imagine malgré tout
[Musique]
il numéro on leur dit d'après ce que le
plus joueur basescu de l'add
on mais ils sont rentrés pas enfin là
c'est là vous regardez que de la prépa
encore n'est pas encore rentré dans la
partie en réalité ici non
ça c'est quelque chose qui est important
à savoir fab
géré les fonds c'est court
et pas de manquer une différence quand
le client c6 ou pas c'est que tu faire
ces six pour blinder d'habitude tapas je
m'attends à ses 6
c'est possible que great food fasse
partie de l'équipe de dépôt à oui c'est
possible
mais c'est l'inversé très possible ce
faire ajoutez moi aussi mais là ça tombe
sais pas mais pourquoi pas en fait
des français malgré tout il n'a pas fait
ses six pour renforcer il a fait des
français
surprenant ou pas je sais pas mais en
tout cas c'est sa prépa partir par la
bastille est ce que je pensais mais
pourquoi avoir attendu qu'il ya trois
pour faire un pas de le prendre du fou
comme gagne parce que tu as des âmes b3
qui traînent ou des fruits vii d'hommes
b3 mais
les petits être plantés sont des cinq a
tellement envie de te faire
mais je pense que le prendre des deux en
fait
on peut pas prendre du pillon juste
pascal cat en l'air puis je crois qu'on
a pour narguer tout court en fait les
gens se demandent toujours des hausses
toujours des questions on y répond
en amont de manière prophylactique
pour que 15 passage chez sneakers
hurricanes on savait que c'est une vraie
question je sais pas pourquoi c'est un
moment qui la joue plus en fait déjà la
coupe du monde et de la page web
donc si bien mais il doit y avoir un
problème quelque part ouais ou tête ils
en ont marre de la van trier qui est des
cinq rapide non
non des échecs est ce qu'on soit comme
muse garde son titre tout donner vos
bras je pense qu'elles les deux il ya
des gens qui pensent que c'est très mec
soit magnus c'est un bon ambassadeur du
jeu et c'était un ado qui pensent ses
murs nouveau tas de tout bon touriste la
chance probablement rien ça change pas
grand chose en fait mais je n'en ai pas
et pas une haine pour l'un ou pour
l'autre convoi selon qu'il yad'autres
qui gagne ou qu à
ccc partager on peut être plus fan de
lin ou plus fan de l'autre mais y'a pas
un consensus qui te dis ouais on veut
que ces machins gagne quoi
sur la russell et dernière fois il était
dans le dur sa dernière chevêche
cavaliers des cinq perdues mais il était
mieux contre carla qui n'arrive je me
rappelle c'est d'ailleurs un moment il
faut revenir
mais ils lui font tout ce qui est des
cinq mois bah oui il faut des cinq
autres ont
donc de quoi prendre ces quatre jeux
c'est pas la bonne question en fait
moi je prendrais du cavalier bah je
pense c'est cadeau cinq scellés
tellement belle ça justifierait sa
kallio 3 ça on pêche a priori des cinq
quand même bien comme il faut quoi et
donc voilà tu vends ma sympathie il est
couvert par un
gendarme s'était pas fait je me demande
d'être un
ton but en pro b de la fin et on met la
barre on leur dit puisqu'il a été
analysé
et mais ça ça déjà c'est à pas à
l'élysée en amont
oui il faut tu auras fait chier deux
fois tu joues pas tempo mais alors
depuis cavaliers ok mais enfin ça
justifie me ya quand même un truc qui me
chiffonne à chaque fois c'est comment on
te dit il faut du temps pour bien jouer
aux échecs oui c'est vrai en fait
l'année pour une nouvelle fois le cas
les français car il aurait joué tempo
c'est sa prépa il a encore gaspillé
quand même a minima 3 4 minutes sur une
partie qu'est ce qui vraiment une au
moins un quart d'heure à marcher comme
ignoble certes ils n'ont vraiment pas
besoin des deux enfin
très important de marché à tous
ça me chiffonne quand même parce que
c'est un tu as l'impression que 90% du
tantad au moins un des deux joueurs qui
n'est pas si sûr si on faisait une stat
avoir les deux joueurs assis en même
temps c'est rarissime
ouais pourquoi chronométrer le temps de
présence et de la table ça doit être
famélique là on a de nouveau elle et les
photos rihanna table
trouve ça un peu et ça ça me chiffonne
jeu chiffonné c'est chaque fois
me disant l'écran dans la loge oui mais
bon
un jeu qui joue sur un échiquier en fait
pas sur un écran
13 comme c'est pas c'est très bien moi
j'ai mer mais
ce qui passe quand même un temps à pas
être assis sur leur échiquier qui est
qui est quand même
assez particulier quand même femme ouais
enfin j'imagine sur sur toutes les
personnes qui découvrent les échecs de
haut niveau et qui découvre ses tournois
ils doivent être étonné il revient ces
six avec le cheval non qui l'empêchent
qui a rallié à 5 m 1
ok bon
bon la séquence m'impressionne pas mais
elle est forte c'est sûr ne sauverait
pas mais faire cavalier seul tu te prend
ses quartiers thématiques et tu reviens
en c6
c'est que juste en fait je parle des
coûts est vu comme ça c'est pas
impressionnant mais c'est sûr ces forts
en fait
l'impression de voir un match de soccer
en fait on a la taille étant assis à
côté il habille en joueur de soccer non
mais c'est particulier quand même et qui
sait si ce n'est pas aussi j'attends de
pain s'y attendait pas
là il va réfléchir
en fait c'est chacun son tour
mais c'est vrai que si on enlevait les
écrans tactiles obligé d'être assis
en fait tu enlèves les écrans qu'ils
veulent dans la salle de repos vous fait
des démarches au col athées ou des kakis
très bien pour eux et être juste devrait
remettre un petit bip heures pour dire
ça tout de même pas voilà toute attaque
à vérifier quoi
tu vas pour me mettre une pendule blanc
noir et on s'acquitte
de 60 pourquoi tu aurais eu droit à des
écrans j'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi d'al-khoms à l'écran salle de
repos dans la salle de repos du trp
aussi tu veux à calcul et à un échiquier
à je sais pas je trouve je trouve ça
vraiment ridicule un personnellement
mais
c'est un combat entre deux hommes c'est
la beauté du jeu quand même cet
affrontement où c'est que moi qui vis
dans mon délire
j'ai l'impression que c'est un combat
entre deux hommes s'en rendit c'est un
genre de combat de boxe intellectuelle
ou quoi et je trouve que c'est le cas
mais
[Musique]
je veux tu peux avoir une présence un
charisme qui te dérange ça doit faire
partie du jeu non ouais y'a que moi qui
a doté des rangées de l'absence le
spectre de karine kaiser mais justement
c'est la présence elle doit elle doit
avoir un impact là c'est bon
je trouve ça pas du tout pas du tout
spectaculaire et même assez dérangeant
personnel
bon disons en fait on n'a pas l'habitude
même dans ces matches là c'est cette
année ça c'est particulier
je me rappelle moi comme j'avais c'est
les caméras pour carlson à caruana tu
voyais tu voyais déjà l'autre parfois
complètement
la donne oui mais pourquoi au moins il
est là il est là il a vachement il te
monte à cheval si je t'emmerde les
calculs toi tu es joueur tu avais un
truc quand même temps d'un qui calcule
la fonte à l'autre avachi enfin je
trouve que ça fait même partie du jeu en
quelque sorte et de la beauté du jeu je
trouve qu'en lever ça s'est
[Musique]
passé en libye
un truc parce que la présence physique à
l'échiquier pour moi elle elle fait
quelque chose quoi
alors une règle étaplois teulet
d'accueil lorraine pose toilette de
trois minutes comme au tennis quoi
se lever ça me dérange pas mais oui moi
je le fais moi-même mais je veux dire
pire si je le reste à suivre sera signé
mais bon à voir l'écran à côté enfin de
toute façon les échecs tu joues sur un
jeu là encore une fois des joueurs y au
mieux et
c'est normal mais
après ça devrait enfin pour moi
j'suis pas fan qu'on va dire ça comme ça
je ne suis pas fan
l'absence aussi partie du jeu bouffe
je vois pas dans lequel fin c'est quand
même si au tennis ferment le terrain
fait y'a aucun sport où tu pourrais
faire ça absent du jeu qu'en fin au foot
sur le banc de touche
quelqu'un qu'ils disent geisink les
blind fold any way je pense pas
je pense que deux pas du tout voire
l'échiquier c'est dérangeant la force
aucun endroit mais ça ils peuvent aller
ils peuvent le blind fold mais tu joue
moins bien ben folds en général un petit
peu respectueuse de la concentration à
te remémorés même si ça va tu sais faire
mais moi je pense que je joue pas
beaucoup moins bien avec cauet mais
c'est juste quand même de l'énergie plus
j'ai jamais fait partie à la veulent
qu'il y aura six heures dont je ne sais
pas où d'un moment si ça ne m appelle à
samedi
je ne viens pas
mais voilà il faudra aller plus loin qui
vous tous les ans salle de repos qu'ils
aient la chicha fin ils sont là assis
fumeurs chicha ya un genre des d'un
écuyer ça qu'il va jouer ton quoi taper
le coût va ramener qu'ailleurs ccist
hélas oui enfin là je serais pas contre
en fait les deux ans avant leur salle de
repos machin chicha c'est quand même
fort ton sac au boeuf
après bon le mec doit bien grand soutien
si mike hayes ans 6-8 ans et six à pas
de chance pas de chance a choisi le mot
véhicules dans leur métier qui est
toujours des chats il le sait en vingt
ans de carrière il n'a fait qu'une seule
erreur de placement pièce ait notent ils
comptent vraiment très vite
il fait vraiment très bien les chichas
linde numéro un dans mon ordi et écoute
plus logique un
parent est très logique tu mets la tour
sur la colonne ouverte
et peut-être tu perds des idées comme
cavalier à 5 à un moment il ya un
échange sup rendu foutu presse un peu
ses 7 verset peut-être une menace qu'il
ya cinq ans vous prendrez d'accès cette
étude menée sur le faux problème soit
la pelote twist en fait là ce sont les
deux expliqué
c'est marrant
mais de qui se bat mais ça ouais ça
rajoute un combat psychologique comme au
poker mais même au snooker tu es obligé
de rester neutre ailleurs ne peut pas de
bars et une salle de repos il tape
tebbal moi je me bats avec jouer qu'on
était obligé mais ça met une pression va
tu regardes le mec mais triste et
dégoûté et aux fléchettes à stephen lang
qui
avait fait 181 été obligé de regarder
avoir envoyé de fléchettes et et moi je
suis allée fiche est dans ta gueule
[Musique]
tu es magnifique
complet ce
réveil contient en 1181 enfin vous le
disais tu peux faire
pour ça oui tu veux qu'elle valait à 5
cavale et prend fou prend étapes et sur
ces sept visuellement les blancs ont
l'air mieux mais après c'est sûr que ces
rondes il a mais c'est sûr qu'on n'a pas
encore vu un coût de la partie là on
voit que des coûts d'ordi bon et pau
dupont ca soit et doit se remémorer soit
il a conservé avec force et 1 et
magnus je ne sais pas il infléchit mais
peut-être qu'il réfléchit pas vraiment
dans le sens où voilà c'est lui qui le
premier a ajouté ici 6,5 ou un peu
étonnant un coût qui change et
ça ça répond le coup plus évident donc
normalement tu sais où tu t'arrêtes
accueilli 6,6 et que ça que ça va mais
pour moi d'aller plus loin leur époque 4
un peu plus fin que ça
et quoi dire d'autre
bon après les blancs je pense jacques
hyest ces menaces mais tu peux éviter
pour me tais toi même le pion à 5 ou
peut-être d'autres coups c'est pas
et
les loteries et des blancs c'est
peut-être juste de mettre le fond c'est
trop et faire des quatre dons comme gary
quoi
ça peut
prénom s qui peuvent te balancer un
petit 10 inco
ça peut perdre sur près de déguisement
qui est ce que
est ce que c'est jouable c'est
complètement
à la ramasse et qu'on salaires témoigne
au
salaire quand même très très con en fait
fab
bas symptômes - non mais j'ai juste
regardé parce que faut toujours regarder
ah bon vu que c'est un peu débile hausse
ces bonnes nouvelles pour des bons
oeufs
[Musique]
à
5 pour moi c'est plus logique enfin oui
et non cci de calais à 5 et donc tu
prend position sur la case en termes de
structure pions c'est cool tu fixes un
peu le b2 mais tu te fixes à 5 aussi
dans ta touche pas trop et tu donnes une
petite dame d2 après et d4 peut partir
donc
à 5 ces responsables rires j'ai
peut-être très bien c'est peut-être le
meilleur coup
mais bon tu peux pas le faire sans
réfléchir
reid
je sens précis où ça c'est moi le
spécialiste cas je sais tu vois les tél
non non la preuve en est normal à
stresser
irréfléchi mais il est normal que gagne
le grand spécialiste international
de la lecture de le
visage de ma nièce de relais vonn a
complètement confirmer ce que j ai un je
t'aime assista dessus bah si j'aime bien
avec les yanks yeux j'ai toujours dit en
fait
je sais pas j'aime pas tellement la
pression normes
y a rien d'alarmant mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait exactement quoi
mais bon moment il est pas inquiet tu
penses qu'il a pu inverser sa prépa
comme hier non
non mais surtout si ces six celle qu'on
lui rende il voit un tout petit peu
d'eau ça ça traduit l'anxiété voire une
seulement une gorgée d'eau comme ça ça
traduit l'anxiété oui c'est pas nouveau
et sauf ouais c'est pas une vraie soif
assez terrible il anxieux
aller oui mais bon j'ai le ride j'y peux
rien
il a voiture il ya vu un peu d'eau c'est
parce qu'il a abou cissé un petit peu a
séché par l'anxiété le stress oui ok
c'est fini c'est fini les amis cette
gorgée d'eau on dit beaucoup attendait
très long dommage pour une époque il
n'était pas en phase il aurait su il
aurait su devant son écran
la remise car bien
banis vraiment pas très bien depuis le
début du match je son propre aveu bon la
princesse est aujourd'hui un constant il
a joué les coups qui connaît pas mais ça
doit mais oui bah c'est jamais jamais
plaisant de savoir que tu joues pas à
ton top et que tu le sais tu sens
n'était pas content non mais surtout
qu'il est c'est un gagneur et il est
exigeant envers lui-même donc ne peut
pas se satisfaire de ce genre de
conneries je pense pas qu'ils s'en
satisfasse
je ne pense pas femme
qui puisse dire - sacrifie 14 profondeur
33 non mais si jamais la croissance
avant la position et la pression ça va
être même 0-0 en fait puisque cette
analyse a alors dit profondément et on
doit être
mai
[Musique]
à égalité
magnus porte un lourd fardeau pour ce
match veut dire y avoir 50 locaux sur la
chemise vannetaise
ya plus unibet aujourd'hui un ca on a
changé faty change un jour sur deux
sympa
et là maintenant il a la tête penchée
c'est ainsi rate c'est un signe
non mais à vrai dire la position elle
n'est pas grave ça c'est doit être à 5
le coup et ça doit aller mais c'est pas
je sais pas ça sain qu'il y
avait un coup très bien mon ordi
enfin à cinq rangs 1 mais je sais pas
après tout ces trois j'aime pas trop
mais c'est faux s'est vite
taillé à 5 es tu veux faire quand même
si je peux être qui avait 6 août oui
mais bon je pense une bouffe tu bouffes
et il revient peut-être je sais pas trop
et il se barre avec le cas y aura sept
salerne dégueulasse
ouais mais peut-être que les orions de
dire ça va ça va mais bon c'est en est
réduit à jouer ça
a scellé même logo chaque jour mais en
fait on a tellement regarde le unibet il
est la chose de plus en fait ouais c'est
lui qui changent de place donc avec les
calmes autre chose on voit autre chose
ah non ils sont toujours là oui mais non
il avoue je suis rassuré
je suis les fab j'étais
anxieux
les joueurs travaillent leur body
language comme au poker pas vraiment je
reçois on essaye de ne pas trop laisser
transparaître leur société un prêté à
des gens très expressif je pense à bâle
kaspar enfants qui eux
qui laissait transparaître ses émotions
mais tu savais mais il le fait aussi
parfois ouais parce que tu pensais avoir
toujours su alors que non
pas des fois il fait semblant de ne pas
savoir alors qu'il savait mais sinon oui
quand tu vois que ce soir confiant qu'il
était envoyé la sauce qui pouvait faire
peur en fait
justement de censure les brad aurait
coûté moins cher que ceux sur la chaise
du long terme de temps d'exposition m'a
clairement c'est vrai que le phosagro il
est vraiment bien passé sur la chaîne
données sur la chasse aux dépôts
est donc juste pour vous compreniez
ainsi sorti cavaliers à 5 pourquoi c'est
chiant
j'ai refait tourbe et 8
qui avait mené à cinq elle y prend fou
prend en attaque ces sept on se dit bon
bateau solide pour défendre et afu
premier set ça le problème les normands
à résoudre ces gagnants pionsat fait
miroir
mais
bon tu prennes comme ça mais là c'est un
truc très concret en fait et donc le
fait qu'ils aient ce à résoudre pour ça
que tout à l'heure on veut faire à cinq
énormes on voit que le calais viennent
nous chercher quelque chose pour pour
lutter contre ça
voilà donc
c'est pour ça avec magnus réfléchit bien
évidemment ça il comprend le problème
que tu orbite du coup je solutionne pas
tellement tu défends ton foutoir
redéboucher défendre ton c7
et voilà donc à cinq a priori ça fait le
taff s'habituer à 5 mais qu'on dise ça
mais le pion sur une case où il peut
être friable sur un fou ces trois dames
d2 et deuxième truc
ben faut se trompe aussi préparer des
quatre peut-être donc
je pose une question là en vrai on est
d'accord que le prochain coup qui va
jouer c'est un coût qui connaît encore
normalement oui mais je sais pas la
matière et et après pas ici c'est pas
possible pas dans le monde parce que
c'est trop dégueulasse comme bas ou
alors ils passent ils ont réparé
bizarrement je sais pas ce qui se passe
et que juste il a des rustines mais là
c'est plus possible enfin non mais là
non ma faim en fait ce que je veux dire
c'est pas rompu hier
en fait c'est parce qu'ils jouent sur
des quatre tubes l'un d'eux l'a grünfeld
parce que bon c'est a priori plus
logique mais tu te dis bon quand même
tête il va changer
et donc tu as un truc surtout ça reste
un des reines qui l'a jamais joué assure
sur la slave sur ok normale et tu te dis
bon s'ils veulent animaux bon je rentre
pas dedans et je pars sur la catalane
est sûre cette variante là je teste pas
à 4 machin partie discipline comme à
charbon ça me saoule j'ai une petite
idée elle va aller pour une partie et on
verra donc c'est peut-être la même chose
pour cavaliers à 5 qui arriveront à ses
mails a en fait donc en fait ça va être
un truc goûter pas très profond tu te
dis juste ça va ça jouer je me démerde
mais là en fait c'est pas maintenant
fait un peu plus de vision tu sais que
ça restait quand même être espagnol alex
est le coeur du répertoire enders son
principal pour l'instant et donc
normalement tu connais bien surtout si
tu viens que ce qu'est de cette crise et
six
étrangers quand arrive la saaq si tu
connais pas plus loin
c'est dur en général on peut arrêter une
prépa et de regarder plus haut et les
gens recommencent à plus trop savoir
surtout avec les noirs quand la position
tu as l'impression que tu peux la jouer
seul dieu que j'ai pas besoin de
connaître plus loin sur l'échiquier je
vais trouver mais là c'est pas le cas
bah c'est toujours très compliqué pas de
telles menaces à défendre donc
il faut bien la déformant
way
avoir un sirh
s'il y arrive
mais oui donc se fasse juge le marché
est sonné qui récite pas là
souviens pas bien je sais pas un truc
bizarre ce qu'il ya en fait c'est ce
qu'on pense ce qui s'est mal sony sa
ligne
qui savait qu'il y ait du fou et 3 et
laverty interverti et parce qu'il a
loupé local ya ces 5 n'était pas facile
ce n'était pas facile mais cuba n'est
pas trouvé assez binaire
et qui réfutait son nombre de coups
après les paul avait peut-être peut-être
justement parce que lui il était pas en
mode mémoire mais en mode jeu ouais et
comme carl scène essayer de faire
remarcher son fichier bon là on l'a bien
d'expliquer ça dans la vidéo sur youtube
que peut-être du coup comme le fichier
remarcher québec a dans ce sens là
c'était pas si facile de penser à
caissargues il a fait le coup le plus
logique fab
non mais après peut-être qu'il l'a et
que justement il sait que quand tu fais
à 5 vous visez mérite ni quoi
donc ma tête qu'ils essayent de se
rappeler plus loin dans son fichier
enfants s'appellent qui est trois quatre
coups de vent et
parce que comme bon ça j'ai déjà dit
hier mais on prend leur dire chaque jour
comme en fait tu aimes pas le frein et
coutumes tout arrive sans avoir jamais
réfléchi a vanté à froid c'est mieux de
prendre ton temps et de faire des trucs
ce qui se passe là quoi
surtout que le temps ils en ont batta du
temps et donc t'es pas obligé de
de te presser
dans des dix quartz pression je sais pas
mais c'est fou ces trois salles et vous
qui nous plaît le plus à y avait quatre
cd ouais ça peut être unique et b4 tout
à fait alors pour l'instant il ya
probablement qu'il prend à 5 qui nous
pendait mais si un jour on peut le
mettre sur cette case c'est pas mal
ouais donc ou c3 je pense bon je suis
pas obligé mais ça fait deux choses ça
prépare dam des deux pour viser à cinq
ans après par des quatre peut-être
globalement sa place sont fous sur une
meilleure a globalement c'est pas cela
de pommes il ya peut-être d'autres
possibilités mais j'aime bien
à bien comme x 2 on pouvait le penser
s'il faut il faut c'est à 17h mais s'il
ya besoin oui vaut mieux vaut mieux
faire ça que le perdre bref oubliez que
les noms aussi le plan qui a aidé cette
crise et 50 qui va toucher ici c'est
d'ailleurs peut être chic et 17,5 ou
d'amd de crise et 5
bon alors je sais pas si on fait de
mener 2 1
mais qui a 17 bien sûr ça peut être une
option
après là je vais gagner quand même le
pion
sa paire de 36 et 47 dans des pions -
ouais peut-être dame 17 rue il prend 1,5
tu reprendras quatre ans
sa paire de foot
est mal placée ce qui peut pas repartir
ils menacent d'être enfermé tôt ou tard
bon je veux redire qu'il ya 17 jours et
des matières binsfeld
alors l'histoire des chaises ils dégâts
ne vous inquiétez pas en fait l'année
peau il est en train de réfléchir depuis
la salle de repos en fait ce qu'on a
réussi à savoir hier c'est qu'il ya un
écran de contrôle en salle de repos et
yann
et yann bêtement il regarde regarde il
réfléchit sur le
depuis là-bas c'est à 50 minutes de jeu
c'est pour ça je vois la première
sa première angels
n'ont pas aidé sa fin sur la honte
regarder si tu veux
contrôler
donc ouais surtout ces trois qui a aidé
cette éventuellement des quatre
sélections voiturier net
ed je pense non tewanee prendre
tu fais pas mal et tu peux faire
peut-être qu'ils essaient 5 mais bon
faut ces deux
et je sais pas toujours en tomba j'aime
bien les blancs bah ouais je suis allé
dans ton genre qui l'écossaise tu
entends que l'anti causé 800 bien vrai
ça ressemble une écossaise qui s'est
bien passé voilà tata collecte de tapas
d'habitude leur
tour trois tours machin talent et vous
placez des fois devancé estime qu des
dames gkd match 5 chez ba tu peux partir
par là bas et je pense c'est plutôt un
peu mieux pour les blanches à dire voilà
on va voir je ne sais pas du coup je
sais pas enfin moi mon ordi me confirme
063 c'est plutôt mieux pour les blancs
un peu mieux un
bon coup il vraiment vraiment important
à l'année peau faut pas croire qu'ils ne
réfléchit pas ramassé enfin je vois
beaucoup de gens là qui parle dans le
chat c'est pour ça que je le rappelle
fab ils sont pas habitués un forcément
avoir ce type de spectacle mais là n'est
pas il est très clairement en train de
réfléchir à la position depuis un autre
endroit en fait tout bêtement on n'est
pas n'est pas habitués nous non plus je
dis enfin là à vendre on s'habitue dans
ce match
mais voilà
après c'est
il ya du positif aussi à sa fin c'est
que les échecs c'est quand même un jeu
difficile et que tu as besoin de bien de
temps d'être bien maintenant mais c'est
genre ça va pas être agréable d'être
assis dans une chaise comme ça et il
faut vraiment être dans une salle pour
vraiment bien je d'une salle de repos
avec ton petit état petit bouilloire que
tu puisses faire des petits trucs te
manger tes petites bananes d'eptica qui
essaient c'est vraiment les conditions
optimales optimale pour jouer un bon
direct
mais quand il faisait les macarons pour
jeu pas si mal quand il est passé de
technologie peut-être pour ça que le
niveau monte en fait
ont très bien dans ce match championnat
du monde il vaut de jeu exceptionnel 1
on l'a on l'a dit on l'a répété fable
pour le moment ça ça joue la siere vous
lassiez je pense fabre que sur ses deux
premières parties
on est sur un niveau très qualitatif et
et on va peut-être
déjà dépassé le plus grand match de
l'histoire inquiétait le dernier quart
ouanna top san juan à karlsson mai mais
peut-être aussi même dépassé en termes
de hype et deux de tension un psy shirt
parce qu'ils 72 à mon avis on est on est
en train de on est on est en tout cas
sur relègue aux oubliettes karpov et
kasparov sur des intermédiaires très
haut et wii wheel et karpov et kasparov
scène en parle on en parle déjà plus et
il y avait déjà eu un ce combat
psychologique aussi de lever de changer
de salle dans le match qui opposait
fischer à ce stade pas ce qui est tout à
fait y avait eu un petit peu ce même
genre de de combat psychologique je ne
veux pas être ainsi dans cette salle moi
je voulais jouer dans la salle de ping
pong et
c'est vrai qu'on est en train de semer
c'est peut-être pour ça on se dit fisher
plus grands joueurs de l'histoire celui
a déjà compris que j'aimais comme ça non
c'est mieux dans une salle de ping-pong
alors bon d'image et une salle de repos
comment encore mieux quoi
extraordinaire gamme sur les peaux on
l'a pas on n'a pas souvent à l'écran on
en profite et on en profite c'est pour
ça qu'il n'a pas de sponsor les sponsors
sont sur la chaise
je sais que sans rigoler mike tyson un
bras qu'il a fait des sponsors adverse
s'étaient placés sur les semelle de la
chaussure
bonjour pas être cochée saleh qui se
prend un chaos dans la tronche et du
coup mais on va reste sous la semelle
feraient route
[Rires]
plus voir
histoire vraie
pamart ou tel truc c'est beau c'est une
aventure besombes
inventé je peux inventer des trucs
extraordinaires mais ça non
et pour la salle de repos c'est pas de
l'invention non pas just que les gens en
fait c'est vraiment pas du troll
est fait sur un écran comme sur internet
ça ne perd pas l'essence des échecs de
plus il y en a qui ont mis plus de
mécanique et 3d que 2d donc cela n'aide
pas ceux qui calculent moins bien bas
mois par an qui suivent meilleur sur un
échiquier 2d je vois mieux juste
simplement et clairement ça m'aiderait
en fait d'avoir un écran moi ça me file
un coup de main pour mieux jouer mais
après ça je dois dire pourquoi pas parce
qu'on fait déjà tellement de choses
contre le spectacle pour avoir une
qualité de jeu donc c'est à dire une
cadence très long enfin je ne fais déjà
tellement de choses qui vont à
l'encontre du spectacle que si ça lui
permet un moment donné au lieu de jouer
la troisième mine de l'ordi de jouer une
fois la deuxième et de la troisième
c'est cool quoi non mais bon tout cas je
faisais trois ça c'est bien donc à la
rigueur ça ça m'embête pas mais après il
pourrait mettre l'écran dans la saint
john à 6 pour le regarder comme icare ou
ouais comme icare ou au plafond quoi
surtout qu'on perd le côté humain de
l'affrontement l'abattement sur les 17
premiers coup t'as pas encore vu un coup
des deux joueurs en fait là actuellement
la bombe si on regarde ce que des coups
tordus en fait fin là ils ont tous fins
et que des turbines qui ont tourné le
combat humain n'a pas encore commencé
dans la partie de toute façon mais là je
suis intéressé de ce que va jouer comme
ça n'en fait pour essayer de résoudre
les problèmes parce que mais c'est sûr
que c'est prêt enfin c'est surtout
intéressante voire en dessous ce risque
dix ans je suis curieux parce que moi
même je ne sais pas
j'ai beau regarder un petit peu avec la
turbine est ça me semble pas pas évident
que
pour le moment ils font travailler une
part de l'intelligence qui est important
c'est la mémoire mais non c'est pas
facile de se rappeler et très
honnêtement par faisait en fait je me
souvenir de ça ça s'est pas fait c'est
pas dur se souvenir de sa
particulièrement mais quand même c'est
que tu doit se faire de ça et de tout le
reste c'est ça tu peux pas ça avance on
voit sur la tombe est donc non
mais c'est vraiment très dur là pour la
peine enfin en tout cas moi ce que les
quantités de choses qu'ils apprennent
j'en serais absolument incapable
toi tu serais capable d'apprendre autant
battre kim pleure je sais pas si je
serais encore capable je pense une
époque j'aurais pu
à dix jours a bu je sais pas en fait un
jeu parce que j'ai jamais eu aussi de
tels fichiers donc ça se joue à de tels
détails et des trucs se ressemblent en
fait en gros ça marche après ça marche
plus
donc non ça c'est quelque chose de dur
quand même moins ferme n'aurait pas la
capacité intellectuelle de le faire donc
c'est vraiment très difficile ce qu'ils
font mais on valide mais je veux dire
par là que la is ils jouent pas vraiment
aux échecs si l'emploi à leur mémoire
aux échecs mais géré c'est pas eux qui
jouent les coûts voilà bah ils n'ont pas
à les trouver il on allait retrouver
quoi c'est un effort qui est différent
faut pas mélanger les positions faut pas
mélanger les coups c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que magnus a fait l'erreur hier de
cavaliers 5 c'est une erreur de mémoire
en fait ce n'était pas une erreur de jeu
c'est pour ça que le coup a paru bizarre
du coup sa deuxième erreur joe hill
l'explication c'est la mémoire c'est pas
une erreur qui l'a fait ce qui calcule
mal est déjà fait et ce qui s'est mal
rappeler bien il savait qu'avec ayew 5
sait plus à quel moment exactement ils
sont à peu près de l'emplacement de les
pièces team et une position qui
soutenait il cherchait le chemin par où
ça devait se créer et il en a trouvé un
sauf que ce n'est pas parfait québec a
déjà fait qu'ils essaient saint caprais
donc voilà
en tout cas si tu te retrouves dans
cette position centre appelé avec les
noirs l'eau facile est dans la tête est
moins bien foutu sorte à une belle
défense est
là t'es pas bien mais si tu te rappelles
pas t'es pas bien et clairement
mais s'adresse enfin pour le coup c'est
important de savoir ce qu'il faut je
gros le grand gagnant du tournoi embrun
phosagro il se met bien moi c'est pour
ça qu'on a laissé cette gamme haf
magnifique
on voit comme ça la position depuis la
perspective la perspective de magnus et
c'est vrai que c'est assez déstabilisant
à force d'être tout le temps ce n'est
pas évident face à une chaise vidreres
du coup ce serait alors la caméra sur la
salle de repos enfin à la rigueur bah
oui j'ai fait partie de la tâche
ça m'intéresserait dans un dépôt en
train de réfléchir de là bas on va voir
comment est ce qu'il s'allonge et ce
qu'ils s'assoient à mais vraiment
qu'est-ce qui boit qu'est-ce qui fait
quoi fin
des éléments
de réflexion pour le prochain
championnat du monde
pourquoi pas essayer même pour celui là
ouais mais bon là ils vont pas changer
leur dispositif il a joué sous ses huit
hockey
ok
il veut revenir aussi je pense
pour lutter face aux foules mettront
donc lisez sur dan des deux fous aussi
c'est qu'il ya trois
bonnes structures du coc clément
hockey
hebdo qui revient
caisse avait d'intéressant faut voir ce
que me dit howard
pour ça tout de suite
ok d'intérêt sa bombe à une délicate
après dam des deux fils fait un truc
intéressant bon c'est ça une mesure de
me juste pour me dire vous aussi ce
propos ce tour 1 pour défendre à quatre
héros menacée c'est dur d'y penser ça
mais des quatre direct meilleur des cas
direct c'est juste avant le coup le plus
logique est le plus fort mais la
difficulté les échecs c'est le cas 8
fois sur 10 mais quand ils se payent
même si on prend cavaliers prend
quel prendre un prof aussi
le truc très logique
ça un poil mieux que les blancs quand
même en fait si vous êtes fous dessin
qui vous échangez faire rodez tu serais
très bien j'ai vu une partie comme ça
avec un fou ces trois dames des quatre
massacre sur place le cavalier versé 6
d'ailleurs il va bien car le cnca avec
les tours soit kwenge et en plus il tue
le plongeon le survol filet neutre
un joueur qui a un répertoire
d'ouvertures plus restreint comme elle
dans une moindre mesure est moins sujet
aux oublis de près par oui mais il est
beaucoup plus ciblées donc les prépare à
de l'air sont plus profondes
le problème c'est que des fois ils
oublient malgré tout quand c'est très
loin et quoi on a en tête la voirie
compte domingues
les cinéphiles exactement où se joue
entre adam des satins damas vite bolland
17.8 mais c'était déjà le coup 23-25
peut-être
ça ressemble quand même quoi mais malgré
tout donc c'est cette protège je pense
évidemment mais tu es plus ciblée donc
bien plus ou moins ça ça du positif et
du négatif tu vois pas là la partie
contre caruana aux candidats
voilà qui est ciblé particulièrement ou
etc
ouais
bon ça c'est pas la position ça c'est
juste qu'on imagine ce qui peut arriver
c'est des cats est ce qu'on a envie de
faire avec les blancs
mange mange mange mange simone l'epo est
revenu car la scène est parti en fait il
ya vraiment jamais cette dimension
psychologique un an c'est un bad à quoi
cela en face de l'autre c'est vrai ce
que j'essaie je pense que
il ya plus de 90% du temps il y en a
qu'un des deux quoi et un chrono
il est reparti
une époque il se remet à l'imposition
pouce
de meilleure situation pousse
beaucoup
réfléchir il a l'air dubitatif sur le
fossé 8 bon enfin de la question enfin
si on peut s'aider quatre
bandes blanches vous aussi vous aussi ça
ni les six ex qu'elle prend à 5 tu te
prends c'est 5 un
tacle adams pour prend 1,5 et
voilà bon on comprend pas on fait
d'hommes des trois peut-être pour
préparer
et des cinq des noirs logique si l'on
sait moins bien en fait parce que
notamment l'espace et donc d
imagine
tu vas les prends qui s'adonnent tu peux
faire fouras un ghanéen pions parce que
tu es si bien est ce que je sais c'est
peut-être cette position le coeur du
problème
donc il aurait réussi à se rappeler de
un truc
un truc gordini quoi
je sais ça s'est calmé 6,6 g je suis à
peu près sûr c'est un truc comme ça
tout le monde ce à quoi
ça se peut que la au bout du bout du
bout soit égal oui
disons que ça ne gueule bien pour les
blancs mais que si ceux des cinq passes
en force pour les noirs
alors quand égalise en passant par une
phase tout un pur moins pendant un petit
moment mais que tu dois y arriver quoi
[Musique]
bon s'en va essayer je sais pas si c'est
dur mais on va te sens tu as envie tesat
après pas tu fais pas non ça je serai
meilleur par contre si tu sais que ça
c'est à roues de secours dans la finale
et qu'au pire oui avec ta mieux tu fais
quand même ouais
ça s'est passé ferait enfin c'est pas
effrayant c'est chiant à jouer mais
c'est pas méga effrayant
mais il faudrait que je suis ça que tu
fais pas 100% fait non
c'est pas ça mais bon c'est quand même
rassurant de se dire que c'est le pire
que tu puisses avoir dans cette finale
donc ça peut probablement faire ça
puisque des cats c'est juste que tu as
envie de faire et que les blancs après
on peut penser à dam des deux bombes et
le fameux terrain compliqué
et c'est pas pour autant que tu écrases
mais c'est juste la deuxième suggestion
de l'ordi mais des caprices prise prise
faut aussi ce sympa qui évite les prend
1,5 à cause du csa dont tu l'as pas de
base
tapas qui les prend 1,5 à cause de ces 5
et tu te places avec ton font aussi son
vis-à-vis du four b3 du climat paul
cailliez c4 et tu te prépares à faire
des cinq simplifiée
bon
bon bah écoute
a résumé le choix cornélien qu'il a un
ouais bah je crois que ça va rentrer
dans ce qu'on a vu
celle du tout de suite
je sais pas dans combien de temps on
avis
il réfléchit en ce qui pose le pour et
le contre
mais des projets à plus de mal à savoir
lui dans quelle phase correspond il est
beaucoup plus dur à lire un dépôt il est
plus expressif mais n'arrivent pas bon
c'est pas trop ce qu'il express
les mêmes expressions dans
aux côtes il soit ce qui se passe en
fait michael jackson depuis sans plus
ouais fins ouais je sais pas en fait
en fait je sais pas sur la caméra j'ai
du mal à lire en fête quand tu joues la
partie face à quelqu'un tu as ressenti
mais plus parce que oui
on a joué les quatre noms mais c'est sûr
que ça va rentrer là dedans c'est hyper
logique ce que tu as montré en vrai pour
le moment mise à part le le le
alors le cavalier 7 de magnus qui était
un peu étrange
sinon tous les autres coûts sont ultra
logique hein c'est très logique c'est
que des coups normaux qu'on aurait joué
en fait les recettes mais on va dire
qu'il doit être normal de magnus si tu
veux faire c'est 6 sur ces galeries mais
c'était pour revenir trois coups après
cela c'est très bien
donc voilà bon écoute
contre icaro ça pourrait faire un beau
match là que des têtes j'adorerais y
sera magnifique
vraiment voir le plan de m
au plan face
ça peut être le plus beau match qui en
fait des petites images des mecs savoir
peut-être tout le temps qu'ils bougent
regarde même pas la position en fait je
regarde que les têtes le festival des
grimaces quoi
victimes qui ont
peut-être un petit micro une glace qui
coupe le son bouteille le casque qui
coupe le bruit extérieur et tech house
qui est hektik taille qui fait des
petites flèches
intéresse quand je pense
à ben magnifique 1 alors ce qui est
encore plus intéressant que sa femme
c'est une petite petite page depuis
là-bas ça c'est le grand deux journées
à jouer et puis on prend des 4 bat façon
je crois que ça va aller dans ce congrès
dans la finale rsa l'air d'être forcée
c'est pas le mot
mais ça a l'air d'être
inéluctable dr howse
échangeant des quatre
howson game
pour l'instant ça joue pas mal aux
jambes
pour le moment c'est vrai c'est une
partie agréable intéressante on va voir
comment ça a dit loeb ça pourrait être
une turbo d'euros 1 quand même ouais
trop bien ça peut être sûr gaudreault
ah ça y est ma news part pas
zaki a aidé quatre c'est un coup forcé
lycéens
a pas le choix faut prendre des quatre
ce serait pas personne ne va jamais
faire
non je veux tu qu'il prend ça c'est sûr
il n'y a pas d'autre option
la france est vraiment le goût forcé
ses jouets
et donc
prends fois aussi ce
vrai quoi et les coûts qui vont avoir
lieu qui est prendront dame prend là
encore vous prends ça fait aucun sens de
bouger une deuxième fois le fonds va
centraliser la dame se mettre sur la
diagonale mille fois que logique et
fotsis virtus entre les stades a dû
créer une batterie verger cette attaque
à cinq
la prépa par contre elle doit s'arrêter
à un moment donné paris sinon
je suis patient âgé sexe est faux aussi
cédé 5 bucco ouais mais peut-être que
dame et je pense que c'est le cas ici
imbéciles on met quatre aussi
il doit savoir jusqu'à l'arrêt
touché 4 et 6 nuls ça fait aucun sens en
fait ça tape sur rien alors que le four
b3 il tape sur ton rock
tu as envie de venir mettre le fou pour
le
nathan vis-à-vis non mais faut aussi se
tape un peu la pièce non protégés en b3
faut aussi garantir
je vois pas toujours ici
est la prépa elle peut être jusqu'à tam
détroit est la prépa elle peut être
jusqu'à on va on va voir
c'est quand même fou ans le niveau de
préparation des joueurs sont tellement
dur enfin vraiment c'est
dans ce si le travail scientifique
c'est vraiment vraiment difficile
c'est vraiment pas évident
si si j'vous tempo est salissant ouais
je sais pas quel point il se rappelle de
tout si long que dix minutes pour jouer
tout l'ouverture très vide en évidence
on ne peut pas investir autant de temps
pour retrouver tu sais à peu près mais
et du coup t'as pas forcément
d'ouverture d'ailleurs compte toujours
un rapide où on lance
des trucs fait en plus avec en serbie
depuis doit être agréable à jouer et
l'évaluation objective bon si tu vois
pas trop - 3 1 t'as pas vu un cambiste
automne une garde comme ça mais et
stafford enfin la farce trafford
ces pièces oui c'est ton truc non c'est
pas toi t'as pas un gaulliste à fordoo
quoi je vais jamais à médias juste jouer
des choses normales et même site à -0 2
tu sais que c'est pas automatique pour
eux c'est déjà beau va + 0 de safe
quasiment faisable déjà très heureux
quoi donc donc voilà donc c'est ça la
différence
entre thomas par thouars rapide et est
longue je pense douter un truc facile à
jouer même c'est un poil moins bon mais
ça va quoi c'est pas la cata mais facile
elle met en pratique le retrouver les
coûts tu vas tu va dérouler
et là tu perds un tri plus difficile
mais tu peux te faire confiance à ta
capacité de calcul
attaque capital gérer ce genre de
situation est donc voilà
c'est toute la différence entre
les cadences dépôts qui revient
bon alors bon je sais pas s'il va faire
dam des trois ans à savoir contre ça
c'est pas dit c'est a priori un bon coup
après ça après pas ça peut ne pas être
dam des trois
savoir que dam des trois cette finale et
c'est en fait un poil moins sûr que des
potions sa prépa
carlson je suis sûr car c'est sur mais
bon
ça peut être bon bah je suis pas mal
je clique quoi
je comprends ce que tu viens parce que
alors pourquoi femme dit ça je veux
juste revenir mais parce que le
truc de carlson de fer qui aura lieu le
7 pions prend et carré lisse et si c'est
vraiment étrange cette séquence de coûts
et donc vraisemblablement
les blancs n'ont pas préparé ça non
alors que carlson en ayant préparé ça
c'est sûr qu'il y joue un truc moins bon
entre guillemets ou moins logiques mois
logique je sais pas si c'est moins bon
en fait même moins logique mais du coup
lui connaît bien en contrepartie connaît
bien ça ils sacrifient un petit peu de
positions entre guillemets ou de
facilité de jeu contre de la
connaissance bah ça est
bon tout cas
on est pour la jouer des coudes logique
jusqu'à présent mais en fait oui c'est
peut-être plus facile enfin même si ce
tronc pour fait c'est pas dangereux non
ok brassens ne fonctionne pas et ses 5 1
c'est important quand même c'est vrai
que c'est une bonne question mais on l'a
dit tout à l'heure mais oui c'était pas
la tue pas le deviner ses 5 c'est chiant
ça tacle adams attaque le cavalier est
d'amener de défend métaphore prend b3
puis prendre prend 1,4 je sais pas si
noir son mieux mais en termes de
structure un peu mieux quoi ta que 4 tab
et de un peu isolé
sincèrement ça rit sacrifie un peu de
facilité de jeu on va repasser à part
depuis le début puisque roy a le petit
bug on en profite mais où ils sacrifient
un tout petit peu de facilité de jeu
contre de la
profondeur de préparation
donc notre
cher ça va le sentir un peu on tue
badauds écoute tu écris atx est comme un
frère au white witch what we choose
c'est comme ça
ça fait plusieurs fois que je vois ce
genre de remarques qui sont plus
destinés à kiev puisque c'est notre nom
mais vous lui demandez souvent et vous
demande aussi sur les vidéos youtube de
sa chaîne perso bitstream et là en fait
c'est surtout chez scor ces deux choses
différentes à bois de kiev la même
personne c'est des trucs différents ce
n'est pas de son fait en fait c'est pas
lui qui décide de mettre de la pub à de
la pub c'est qu'il faut mettre six
minutes par heure ces normes il donc un
bail de faire et c'est comme ça en fait
donc après c'est vrai que c'était
abonnés et que t707 protégés que ça ne
protège pas fo demandé at which le match
sk je sais pas qui mais pas nous non
c'est en fait
mais c'est pas on y parlait en fait moi
aussi ça m'étonne un peu si mon père
seulement ça m'étonne un peu
je comprends pas l'intérêt
c'est comme ça
c'est pas la chaîne de kembs pas la
mienne non plus
rires j'aimerais bien très bon signe
mais non non pas du tout donc voilà en
fait c'est comme ça quoi
mais pour y piocher
une micro-sieste peut-être pas une
technique intéressante un micro sieste
tu dors là comme ça tu prends une
cuillère métalliques quand tu t'en vas
retard relâchement musculaire des trucs
tombe donc tu t'endors à une seconde
peut-être dans le bling 1 il paraît que
c'est un micro c'est très bien bon en
fin de récit est le siesta mai
[Musique]
à vétroz moquetté pour faire ça parce
que hier tombe tu entends pas à tomber
manif à le nombre de micro cesse de deux
minutes que j'ai dû faire dans la vie
j'en ai fait beaucoup
de chasse 55 je vais le réveil à l'heure
pile
j'en ai fait beaucoup ça marche vraiment
faim pour moi après celle de tout un
chacun
pour les blancs bas c'est ce qu'on a
montré tout à l'heure ça n'allait pas
voir
mais il ya des 5
et puis on prend et qui avaient libre en
est fou prend 1,5 et on s'est passé qui
est bicis ou québec est le coup une
quarantaine de savoir ça et globalement
à peu près égale la finale c'était un
crime fut cependant mon pour les blancs
ça ne doit pas suffire pour prétendre à
la vente pas non pour prétendre à
davantage ça suffit et pour avoir un
avantage ça suffit pas c'est ça
objectivement quoi sinon je vais encore
quelques bons coups mais c'est possible
qu'ils aient tous les coups à la maison
tu devrais qu'ils aient déjà vu magnus
et donc
quand tu fais pourtant les instantanés
on va compte en gros manque de sommeil
parce que tu avais pas le temps tu
t'endors vie tout à fait
mais c'est très très vous avez beaucoup
de travail c'est hyper efficace
genre tu récupères vraiment
c'est beaucoup moins de temps vers une
seconde
moi je vous ai une ou deux minutes mais
moi je récupère de ouf
génial quand tu ta vie tu récupères 2
par contre après faut pas oublier quand
tu as fini ton rush de faire une journée
où tu fait que dormir
tu peux faire ça plusieurs jours est un
peu un peu des piles
energizer il dit ça repose de cerveau
c'est un rêve un jour de reset du
cerveau ouais mais juste un mot n'est en
fait ton corps il va là plus trop aimé
il faut bien dormir
là tu peux pas le faire en partie ce
qu'il faut que tu puisses te mettre un
réveil ou faire un truc
on propose food r
mais mme
payette ont fouillé les matchs tu coupes
la vision de thé tour un petit truc
hathaway visuellement presse et blanc
vont pas être moins bien mais ça donne
pas envie d'amener droit c'est vraiment
logique 1 bat déjà vous avez compris
qu'on pouvait reprendre à 5 passes et 5
dans la dame ça donne vous prend
peut-être je sais pas où je le fous ces
trois tu protégera le faux pas souvent à
5 3 des français cas d'un pour cent
quatre vingt cinq états d'âme preuve ça
de suite pour prononcer cette actu vous
même du pion pas
ça devienne menace ou pas
et puis comment tu joues avec les noirs
en fait tu es obligé de faire des cinq
sinon tu veux quoi
je peux y avait un truc bizarre de
l'andi a besoin 15.4 j'ai pas cherché à
comprendre trop chou
parce que pour faire des 50
[Musique]
cm3 est trop fort ça je te dis non c'est
toi ça c'est une connerie de leur 10e
non faut pas faire non mais a cédé 5
c'est sur ces dames des trois dessins
qui
des trois des cinq
noms c'est obligé que ce soit sa
retraite a peut-être d'âme des uns ici
aussi
bon si on fait
il a joué je crois
je passe sur mes jeux non
j'ai eu l'impression
j'ai eu l'impression fab
je peux mettre la position peu fou prêt
à savoir ce qu'il en pense ce mardi
selon ton moins 30 mg et sid pour m et 6
issue de l'opposition
m 4 et qui avait 6 ans l'a pas mal
c'est ça c'est une belle prépa de magnus
un ouais parce que
c'est une belle feinte c'est une belle
surprise et si ça tient c'est juste bien
ça peut ça peut droit à la maison
mais
m
tiff
ouais bon les devants tu as acquis et b6
sa préférence numéros unes mais bon je
sais pas si c'est mieux
ouais c'est plus forcément fait
qu'on a vu cette finale donc dam des
trois des cinq pions prend cavaliers
prend
les pays situés
dans le bas valais prend tout reprend un
beau truc là ah ouais on s'y prend bien
et on prend revient en b3 tour d2 ça
c'est au tour ces deux tours 5 il y
avait plus de tours au magnifique mais
ça doit être ça la prépa en fait j'en
reçois vraiment être ça
si tu retrouves c'est magnifique
why fin du coup pour défendre voyez
plutôt un argument
non
ça c'est hyper facile
non ça c'est hyper facile faites y en a
même qui sont nuls champion b 6
mai où tu m'aimes le foncier 5e but 4-5
ces cinq domaines taurin
et
c'est hyper facile ça ah ben
ça ça je fais je pense
même moi même toit c'est dire ok je sais
pas assez forcé
la vie me ressemble ça peut être la
préparer ça ressemble un truc très basse
à la lune comme sa prépa d' jusqu'à la
fin
c'est beau il va tout ça en combien de
temps un truc s'il n'a pas à le voir en
fait juste il doit savoir avec les noirs
ce serait magnifique
non mais là c'est vraiment l'équipe de
manu ce qui a très très bien travaillé
un
oui
est ce que népotisme peu foiré
raccourcis clavier
est ce que les pop encore fois non non
on né peut pas fait peut pas perdre
enfin mise à part gaffe à tout moment on
peut faire une gaffe gravissime mais
normalement c'est pas une position où il
peut être en danger non
il réfléchit
au gabon c'est tout ça n'est pas lui il
essaye de calcul est vrai il sait pas
mais c'est pas bon signe ce que si lui
connaît pas et que la meilleure variante
cedro en fait je vois pas dans quel
monde
c'est déjà trop
je comprends pas c'est une bonne prépa
que tu veux pas perdre mais vraiment
travail des prépas pour faire du rab
avec les noirs oui avec le noir tu veux
faire nul avec les blancs gagner
bons trucs tous croient jamais lien avec
les landes soit trouver des idées là où
tu penses que l'autre n'est pas les
fouilles et
avoir une chance
non en fait bonsoir vous rendez pas
compte dont vous suivez mais il énorme
différence entre voir ça est ce que vous
avez vu récemment
dans le niveau des prix bas
là les joueurs sont tellement bien
préparé
c'est fou en fait
on peut aller sieste je veux
tu peux bon
c'est un peu
un petit moment semble aussi mais ça
s'est passé un truc moi tu écoutes en
font quoi tu peux écouter en font aller
faire une petite sieste on voit in c est
à ce jour plaisir tant que les pubs sont
allumés en dégustent à hisser couasnon
record d'une consulter au choix du monde
non à 16 doit pas être loin du record
non
oui je sais pas quel record mais déjà
que chaque match commence par 12 nuls
d'affilée donc ses 12000 entière du
match d'avant c'était déjà un record le
max t8 jusqu'à présent choix
kasparov au nombre de 95 8 nuls je pense
non mais gagner un deuxième puits
qu'elle soit à peu près avait
avait défoncé mais
bon le regret peut-être enfin si un
record c'est le match de 84 et je crois
qu'on est fier perso j'ai quelque chose
à côté adrien petit tft côté li fé ri
peut-être hugo qui envoie abbaoui
hergott
son cachet avec quel type d'ordinateur
je vais vous trouvez ça
puis s'en excusent particulier encore un
autre niveau non à la pour ce pour ces
joueurs là c'est au dessus
pour d'etel tu sais
je ne comprends pas le principe des
prépas si c'est pour faire un nul je
sais qu'à ce niveau c'est dur de gagner
clément mais se préparait des heures
voire des journées pour faire un nul
j'ai du mal avec cette mentalité ah oui
bon après tu peux arriver pas préparés
et perdent tout est parti à quesnoy
enfin ça tu peux mais gagne avec les
noix en fait ça va être compliqué quand
même si free qui a fait pas n'importe
quoi c'est impossible
qu'il y avait une série de dix sept
parties d'affilée nul entre kasparov en
84 28 17 hockey entre la partie numéro
13 est la partenaire 30
la guinée à trente et une karpov menait
5-0 après ses terres hier des tranchées
j'ai pas ce genre fait une telle série
après ya eu donc 1 0 un nul ville de
troyes 4 victoires kasparov 5 1 auxerre
3 0 une 2 3 4 5
et puis victor kasparov rue victor
qu'espérait fin du match donc il ya une
fois 17 au milieu du match en fait
mais entrecoupé de victoire il faisait
déjà 80 villas 0 bat magnus avec les
noirs je suis patient déjà si tu veux
vraiment faire un humaniste qui fait nul
conquis la
chebba mais bon dans tous les cas vous
pouvez pas comparer un super ordinateur
non en fait c'est comme si on vous dit
vraiment on à ferrari va puis du cndd
bolt oui
qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout c'est pas nul
hein quoi fin
tu sais vraiment pas vite le marathon
moi je prends je prends de priver
vraiment j'ai vraiment beaucoup plus
grave si vous voulez quoi enfin
je sais pas quelle comparaison vous
faites
la soirée s carlson il se passe quoi
à grand chose à mon avis pour gary
et les retraités en fait c'est quand
même si tu demandes oui et si sampras je
vais contre djoko sur une faille
peut être à même la gouvernance rompre
un sauveur il ya plus de terres trop mal
quoi
qui ces femmes
tu le mets de l'arbre rapide se chauffe
son bras et tu te plantes des animaux
tie break à chaque fois puis après c'est
jamais
complexe et dans tous les cas
mais c'est les échecs c'est difficile
savais qu'avec le temps qui passe l'âge
mais là la baisse de la motivation
surtout
la forme à temps un peu le cerveau façon
qui vieillit comme
mais franchement pour moi de la
motivation c'est le truc principal en
fait
quoi
bon on a plus qu'à attendre la femme on
a vu la variante et la prépa de magnus
question c'est ce que né pauvre a joint
un coup un coût inférieur ou pas
bah peut-être une meilleure idée de juin
coûts inférieurs puis après pas plein
fer elle te prends une nulle sans jouer
un coup quoi
et vous ils sont inférieurs pas trop non
plus en fait
au
dam des trois tellement logique en fait
et si tu connais pas comment tu peux
savoir on a des droits c'est assez
logique frais qui sont faire d'autre
en fait bon tu le vois avec des 5 c'est
ce qui te pend au nez et pourquoi dam
des trois aussi ça peut être intéressant
bas
parce que sur des saints qui peut aussi
réagir en te dire tiens j'ai foucault m6
comme l'idée
de me prendre rendez-vous domination
après bon ben c'est typique sculpteur
s'anime il va jouer la paire de flou
mais peut-être que ça c'est fini les on
va parler mais tu fais ce genre d'homme
c3 il a été changé tu reprends du pion
bon neuf cases noires dit clairement qu
on pense bien mais
bloqua de la carène
donc tu peux tu peux te dire que j'ai
quand même plus de chances tags dans
l'autre
c'est marrant fait en tout les toutes
ces prépas ceinture basé sur un
sacrifice de pions cmv est ce qu
une bouchée
c'est un peu étiré
donc on dit à des cinq massifs invitent
à leur dîner
ensuite ré jus
ce qu'ils veulent bosser encore avec
magnus propre homme
mais pas côté magnus pas pour n'est pas
vrai c'est magnus qui a réussi à
surprendre
aujourd'hui clairement
maintenant la question c'est de savoir s
est ce que né pauvre à réussir à
faire quelque chose ou puff un petit peu
jouer quoi exercer la moindre pression
ou
bras sont du fait nul tu fais tes propos
tu reviens
mais
ça devra lui pose des questions sur ces
anti marshall en tout cas
ces cas là aujourd'hui c'est juste rien
écoute c'est pas faute d'en avoir parlé
dans nos ce travail du sein mais aussi
jouer les espagnols n'en gagnerait pas
une
âme et
pourquoi ça joue son audition ya plus qu
ali reza comme joueur ambitieux au top
niveau moi j'ai pas vu vraiment alireza
mettre à mal les joueurs du top n'ont
jamais sa victoire contre mam est en
fait c'est yann ultime au mieux il fait
des erreurs et que cavaler c'est juste
il joue parce que le match il estime que
les connaissances match lui force à
jouer parce que sinon ils voir que des
nuls et laser va devoir faire nul et
seront pas champions et il joue pour
gagner ils s'en foutent de la médaille
ils veulent le titre donc ils ont mises
en jeu et ils saluent et serait retombé
ça leur tombe et on est quoi mais c'est
pas que il l'a défoncé
en soi quoi
donc oui non mais là n'est pas où je
vais vous dire que vos palmes et
ambitieuse il essaye vi prend un mur on
fait une prépa des coûts bizarre en fait
qu'ils sont très bien analysé voilà
ménéz paul s'est passé dans mon jeu feu
4 je fais mieux le façonneur a fait kg
5e 3
il a essayé bon bah non mais c'est ça y
est c'est trop fort en face et ce serait
une file aux échecs de gagner de gagner
une partie d'ailleurs magnus ça fait
seize partis qui ont fait annuler
ces 16 parties qui réussit pas à gagner
ma glisse même si c'est le meilleur
joueur de l'histoire des échecs et qui
est incroyable mais ça fait seize
parties consécutives de matches de
championnat donc c'est le match où les
joueurs sont le mieux préparé dans les
ouvertures peut pas être mieux préparés
pour ce match et réussissent pas à
passer parce que
le niveau de préparation est trop élevé
la talent et blanc tu te prends part
dans les ventes quoi regarder tu te
rends 28 coups de stockfisch en fait
ouais bah mais
cgc il faut juste comprendre que c'est
comme jouer pendant 28 27 28 cook
l'ordinateur donc faux
ça dure tant que ton adversaire va pas
faire une faute de mémoire en fait tu
pourras pas gagné
on a vu le truc un petit rasta vraie
impression aussi ses prêts parce qu'il
venait lui-même surprendre magnus
alexander wiedow quand il a mis la tour
en attente des huit tours vite je suis
plus calme toi mais tu crois beaucoup de
venin ou quoi c'était nouveau mais
magnus six ans tu as donc il faisait un
petit truc et il a évité le
truc là dessus que ce terme ait caruana
des surprises des mines un peu à droite
à gauche
fiable et solide en et paul kariya
qu'ils n'honoreraient de chasse oui mais
ces deux joueurs sont en préparation
d'un match championnat du monde c'est
comme si tu dis intel a battu en atp 250
djoko
a ri mais bon si ça peut être pareil
quand tu vas jouer en grand chelem
non mais il peut gagner
mais en
fait c'est vous qui êtes fous en fait
surclassés quelqu'un qui joue très bien
mais
mais il vaut pas mieux que quoi toi j'ai
ça
donc ils vont y aurait il va en fait des
nuls et dans un match comme ça il fait
plein de nul mais c'est comme ça en fait
tu peux pas faire autrement
donc la carte zen mal lui en fait il a
l'expérience de ces matches et il s'est
dit c'est que bon il prend il à la
patience avec lui quoi il dit au pire au
pire au pire ça va au rapide je suis bon
et puis bah voilà tant que génère je
souffre pas avec les blancs j'essaye
brouillard il a un peu poussé le bouchon
il va pas refaire un tel truc je pense
dit lui-même en référence de presse
enfin non en interview à la télé
norvégienne carlson il a dit que dans un
tournant normal il aurait perdu jusque
là il ya trop de pression et des joueurs
pas alors maximum mais met clairement
hier il a abusé de mon nom
ne fera pas comme hier mais en vo oui
qu'est ce qu'il advient des nuls quoi
c'est comme ça
ya aussi dans ce genre de match je leur
prépare spécifiquement contre l'autre
joueur dans un tournoi avec huit joueurs
c'est pas la même préparation mais c'est
pas du tout la même chose en fait tu as
raison je vois tout ça ces raisons le 18
il a raison c'est partout pareil en fait
déjà les candidats c'est ces gros niveau
de préparation là c'est encore au dessus
ce que j'étais préparée que contre un
mec en fait tu as ta cible est vraiment
ce mec là mais tu connais tous survie
ouais
alors ne faisons pas or pour chacun la
sienne
mais là n'est pas ça il a compris que
au pire annuler d'une hausse très bien
mais je crois que il pourrait faire
votre
autant premier jour des bons points de
plus que celui dit fier d'être la finale
on sait pas hier bon hier on savait
vraiment et
aujourd'hui
journée d'hier
en tout cas je pense
que la prochaine partie aura le jour de
repos entre les deux on verra on vers un
autre niveau de jeu j'ai vu des
observateurs norvégien qui a annoncé une
turbo d'euros aujourd'hui et que le
match allait réellement commencé après
la journée de repos je suis assez
d'accord en vrai ouais je sais enfin se
l'est dit d'ailleurs avant la partie jeu
je pense qu'ils ont raison et je
m'attendais à ça mais on va voir s'il
avait raison et du coup si j'avais
respect j'avais raison d'être d'accord
avec eux et j'étais aussi d'accor du
fait que le match je pense qu'après ces
trois premières journées le jour de
repos pour quand même bien souffler on
commencera peut-être avoir du spectacle
à partir de la cinquième journée de jeu
mais je m'attends à quelque chose de
différent à partir de
2 mardi de
[Musique]
bons joueurs c'est un peu inquiets
corner pour le début de match en fait
avec les blancs ils trouvent pas de
faille du tout ah c'est très inquiétant
avec les noirs bon c'est pas trop eu
qu'une partie mais
tout cas il aura des parties à jouer il
va pas faire des nuls comme ça je pense
s'en sentent car c'est toujours un coup
et hier il eu sa chance il n'a pas pu
saisir et ça c'est pas bon signe
mais mauvais ici en fait on vous dit ça
dure dernier une partie le jour de
l'occasion en fait faut l'apprendre quoi
faut pas gâcher les munitions peut-être
qu'ils meurent a pas d'autres déjà à ce
possible hier c'était la meilleure
position qu'il est de tout match de
jouer notre jeu 3
je pensais des cinq ans mais attend va
regarder des cinq puis on prend d'un
prends
parce que ce sont des
bons 4
tu me suis bon bah petit justin ferme
elle me prend qui apprend à cinq
reprises des trois prises à 4
fois darricau quoi ouais mais possible
turbo de rhodes on va voir page 3 il va
se prendre des 5 c'est quasi garantie de
son cdd noir pour se délivrer et
[Musique]
400 chercheurs et le gain où il va
toujours chercher à jouer là nul à nant
dès qu'il aura les blancs il va essayer
d'en gagner une et après deux rondes
road route après s'il est mené au score
c'est une autre histoire ancien sa
dépendent du cinéma match c'était mené
chaque partie importante pour essayer de
reprendre de revenir qu'avec les noirs
tu fais pas ça tu fais un truc où ça
joue un peu
d'ailleurs comme karim quand elles
étaient menées il était parti sur
espagnols font ces cinq fins avait
failli coûter cher mais
essayer autre chose
donc
on s'attend à des 5 es prêt car ça ne
peut réfléchir un peu sa priorité h3c
pas dans le fichier
et donc il va checker ce n'est pas un
truc que j'oublie le coiroux qui peut
bien penser 10 15 minutes peut-être
avant de faire je sais pas on est
des cinq
ça va changer
d'un bond et cinq alliés prend
1,5
à tours 4
là ce qui est des trois menaces sûrement
france et 4 rbds et 8
dans le bar dans lequel on peut trouver
malgré
donc
non seulement ça peut faire çà çà çà çà
çà
tu fais comme d'hab' g5 c'est trop
logique
bouffe bouffe
mieux kedrova ses rangs la vente qu'on a
montré c'est la plus logique après
d'autres y en a peut être beaucoup
d'autres est peu dévié à chaque coup
quasiment mais ça c'est vraiment
linéaire est logique ça c'est la
variante en blitz entre guillemets envie
de s'y joue ça on va descendre machin
avec un match 80e a fait dame g5
j'encaisse draw
et la nuit ça ne me fait pas peur
bon écoute
banus il a l'air confiant là en tant que
lecteur du langage corporel officiel de
magnus je te dis qu'il ya la confiance
en soi ouais non mais la regarde y'a pas
eu tout ce stress là il se tient et se
tient droit commun ni fois qu'on y wayne
on est tranquille
hier et hier il a eu un coup de chaud
ouais bien sûr ça se voyait ah bah t'es
pas content une qualité un peu moins
quoi financer les faillites de jancovici
en salle de repos aussi si tu étais très
anxieux
mais ça cligne des yeux mais non là il
est très pâle fréquence ouais
ça clique des yeux
ça réfléchit
aujourd'hui tranquille comme ça
safina 7,7 convient des chances de
débuter avec x 25 % peut-être atteindre
et 27 mai par contre ce match quand même
normalement de report 14 nuls
non je pense le magnus va écraser
j'annonce je pense qu'à un moment donné
mes pauvres à craquer il va pas en
perdre une il va en perdre deux ou trois
bah oui ils vont sans perdre une
c'est ce que je disais au début pour
l'intérêt du match n'est pas gagné en
premier quoi ah oui sinon sinon c'est
raz-de-marée quoi mais la vase comment
ils jouent à
bath savait pas s'il aura mieux
puisqu'il avait hier quoi donc là hier
il a quand même tellement paniqué
ouais non ça va être dur ça va être dur
pour les pauvres dans les ouvertures en
fait
avec les blancs là pour le mans il
n'arrive pas
ouais
c'est bien que y aller pas roulé sur sur
karl scène mais
non
la fête il n'arrive pas trop à le même
pas mettre de petites pressions
bien qu'avec les noirs au final hier un
pour le moment oui mais c'est plus car
ça ne s'est auto fait ça
cale inverse en fait
un bond et poule à face à partie en fait
c'était pas si mal mais
regardez l martyrisé le saumon et maxime
beaucoup de mal dans le cas inverse
la grünfeld à mon avis ça aurait très
bien après d'autres maxime comme des
pauvres a changé il aurait travaillé
très dur et qu'autre chose
mais c'est avec leur score en v1 c'est
patronage de maxime pas je sais pas qui
est roi lantages de compte car le centre
n'est pas le seul mais c'est rare quoi
lison et
fatah sont enfin ce n'importe qui vise à
karlshamn carson trois favoris même pas
le sujet en fait
après bon
circonstances de match il ya qui tiendra
mieux attention sur un gars hier qui se
sont pas nerveux qui encaisse la
victoire bon bah quoi pas quoi j'avais
trouvé d'ailleurs
caruana très bon dans le dernier match
oui
il avait vraiment rien à envier en
partie longue à mains nues c'est juste
qu'il aimait enfant rapide 1 vincent
somme avant et c'était forcément bas les
deux derniers matchs ont finalement
étaient des championnats du monde de
rapides en quelque sorte ouais mais car
là c'est ce qu'il ya de meilleur
impression car yakine vraiment ils
veulent roseaux qui s'accrochaient
s'accrocher il tenait du bout des doigts
et a fait gagner du coup de faire ça
mais on le sentait moins impressionnants
dans le jeu quoi étaient inférieures
alors que caruana franchement quand tu
as vu les quais les douze parties ça
jouait bien oui et dommageable en
carnage un peu moins bien que cette
époque après il peut revenir 1 il n'a
pas lâché en terme de mental etc
d'ailleurs il s'est qualifié la fma dans
un second alors qu'il n'est pas en forme
c'est beau
franchement je n'ai pas du tout cher ce
à quoi je pensais pas qu'elle se
qualifier
avant le tournage on savait rien mais
après trois rondes
il ya une la ronda c'était bien mais
rentrent de effets du grenelle série
avec d'options de plus
est
et rendre trois îles à +5 qu'on ne sache
effet nul tu dis bon ok juste pas en
forme et va publier pas
un grand joueur et malgré ça il s'est
pas sorti de son tournoi il a gagné la
ronde important des clés noires qu'on
grandit lucila revenus machin
bravo à lui en fait
en respect parce que c'est hyper dur aux
échecs d'arrivée malgré tout faire un
stage solide quand tu joues juste très
bien quoi
c'est très difficile c'est la marque des
grandes heures car le sel on est capable
le cid ouais
donc
bravo caruana après ben voila vous il
est moins impressionnant que à l'époque
tout hâtive arrive à revenir je sais pas
mais il serait capable quand
tout cas magnus réfléchi ici
il va envoyer des cinqs quasiment sûr
mais comme tu le disais il va prendre 10
15 peut-être même 20 minutes
ça peut être l'un des derniers coups
difficiles de la partie ouais
baffie roues en fait il en plein devenir
un point le coup très impressionnant ce
qu'il a accompli jusque là j'essaie d'y
amener tout le monde parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'il est plus fort que
carlson quand on vous écoute alors que
encore prouvé info on va gagner combien
d'offres faire des trucs s'est défendue
non mais j'ai retenu enfin
oui donc aussi juste pour calmer un peu
les gens fin mai juste qu'il a fait
c'est hyper impressionnant incroyable
son score aux chemins d'europe regagner
leur ia bah ouais je dis bravo caruana a
lu la faune cremps il a gagné donc donc
non très impressionnant et
ont déjà à confirmer par la suite
et puis voir comment ils évoluent meta
son chéquier très sérieux il travaille
petite pub en même temps il travaille
beaucoup il
à fond sur les échecs
donc donc il a le potentiel d'être un
champion du monde vous dit pas qu'il va
l'être j'en sais rien fait à personne ça
mais il a le potentiel on disait déjà
avant
j'ai fait une interview en début d'année
je disais que je pense ça serait carlson
va garder son titre à un moment et que
le prochain ça sera fierro et oumar
envoyé une vidéo on est sorti une vidéo
il ya déjà un peu plus de deux ans c'est
déjà ça
on n'a pas attendu le mois dernier pour
retenir ça mais juste d'un faux faux pas
est depuis que la musique
réfléchis côté côté norvégien
les norvégiens
il va envoyer le d5 non ouais alors sauf
si l'un d'eux doit de jouer là sauf s'il
est plus que nulle bon choix parce qu'il
veut faire plus mais que ja qui est des
cinq ça simplifie trop il tient en fait
je crains vraiment rien je peux
améliorer je ne sais les mots je vois
pas comment un
témoin il donne l'impression de vouloir
jeu des cinq
oui si on regarde le nombre de coups ça
des fois pour se rappeler des prix passe
peut être par le machin
fléchissent a réfléchi
on pourra voir une partie courte
aujourd'hui un bon départ
mais c'est pas sûr
c'est pas sûr encore ça pourrait durer à
partir de maintenant plus qu'une heure
une heure et demie à mon avis
d'autres peut y avoir plus qu'une heure
et demie de jeu ce qui est courant à ce
niveau là une partie 3h30 c'est une
partie courte oui
or la partie en soit là dessin que ça
change tout on pourra peut être une
partie spectaculaire mais d'un point de
vue de la théorie c'est intéressant quoi
évidemment
c'est moins spectaculaire mais c'est
intéressant
non c'est une partie intéressante en
vrai
si une partie agréable en soi
une mauvaise partie
ça on aura appris quelque chose on enfin
on l'utilisera peut-être jamais cette
idée là mais c'est vrai que ça existe
quelque part un cavalier e set puis on
prend ces 4 ric6 bizarre mais qui tient
sur treize ordinateurs est ce qu a
surtout fait faux bond soit pour partir
enseigner on pourra l'être humain
c'était impossible à trouver
bien quoi topaloff
boy devient sa petite vie tranquille il
joue plus trop une fois de temps en
temps
mais l'impression que l'espagnol c'est
très intéressant théoriquement meka à la
fin il ya là nulle part les échecs étant
fondamentalement un jour où il ya nul à
la fin dans toutes les ouvertures
correct qui aura toujours un nul en fait
ouais tu peux rien y faire si le mec se
rappelle avec les noirs il fera toujours
nul bon c'est le gros défaut d'easyjet
cheikh moderne avec l'ordi
avant ce n'est pas sain pression c'était
très compliqué tu voir vin revient
toujours au même match karpov et
kasparov mieux géré les parties de 90
c'était des 24,5 aussi mais sans et de
l'écossaise trois fois dans le match
tombait des espagnols c'est vraiment
super compliqué
où il ya le feu ce parti où il fait le
voyage de gary etc enfin
mais j'en discute avec valve par rapport
aux systèmes de londres des systèmes de
l'ong s'était jamais joué parce que ça a
donné fin au maximum il surprend les et
valdes aujourd'hui faut mieux tu auras
plus 0 à + 0 2 ah oui non c'est exact
mais en fait il a avant tout pour les
grands-pères qu'on dit quand tu obtiens
est quasiment rien que les blancs petit
avantage vous considérez que c'était
j'avais très mal joué l'ouverture ni
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui comme
l'ordi défend tout partout et qui m'ont
déçu repréparer
00 m toujours revenir à des petits
machins
déjà l'autre
alors qu'il ya à l'époque tu considérais
que tu pouvais toujours prendre un petit
avantage avec les blancs et que si les
noirs défendez bien ce but faisait nul
mais
donc
[Musique]
ouais bah oui toi papa gagnant au cap
d'agde oui mais c'est un temps d'1 me
cale quoi pas dans la cadence lente
c'est un si petit on enfermait août
invite quelques joueurs alors c'est pas
parce que lille joue un peu par ci par
là et zut invite sa petite vie p pause
mais il va pas les deux jours un
candidat va pas jouer les grands prix
élevés des tornado vu comme ça quoi
voilà fin de carrière quand tu pars tu
foutais un peu plus âgés tu vas finir en
mls je sais pas vous mais la chine
les ouvertures classique donne toujours
on va pas plus d'ouverture exotiques
balle encore je veux dire ce que j'ai
demandé posé la question à vlad mais est
ce que c'est encore plus facile de faire
un coup
là il n'y a vraiment rien à savoir tu
sais
pas être fou pour une année et pas vu ce
qu'on pense c'est cuit non je pense pas
que c'est cuit mais disons fillon ou
ayant 12 ans -
by plus jeune donc il ya un avenir qui
semble plus prometteur en nouvelle
zélande et une est déjà il peut se
qualifier pour les candidats il a un
shot encore avec les grands prix et
c'est un format qui lui correspond pas
mal donc il peut très bien le faire
photo candidat tu peux les gagner enfin
effets 2d des derniers mois et donc
c'est pas cuit juste il aura moins de
possibilité enfin voilà comme les plus
âgés il a des jo les candidats on va
peut-être plus jamais ou peut-être une
fois peut-être deux fois mais il va pas
avoir dit possibilité quoi alors que
fillon où tu te dis bon même s'il rate
une fois deux fois il va avoir plein de
chocs c'était juste un simple mais c'est
pas fini pour une nouvelle pour autant
que
l'embauché est encore un bon mois
voilà bah c'est loin d'être fait de se
qualifier au grand prix je suis ils
passent plus souvent favoris ou pas
passée il peut faire d'autre peut faire
aussi
et on verra
magnus
qui réfléchit pour la première fois
réellement dans cette partie et qui est
en train de
tranquillement
évaluer ses possibilités mais là on sent
qu'il est fabien dans une zone de
confort ouais bon moi je pense qu'il
sait que tout va bien mais de façon il
ya deux ans à la pendule donc certains
se précipiter
et provoque théâtre avant des cinq
joueurs peut-être
peut-être quel point 4
de tout reprendre sur des cinq points 6
rebonds
et points 4 on a regardé en fait mais
pas sur
h3g temps précise j'ai bon
d'accord mais vrai alors que la dame en
d3 peut-être tu te faisais un petit
crochet faisait quand la dame
donc non papier prend 80 ans il va jouer
il va jouer il va jouer fab on va le
voir
5 c'était sûr n'ont cessé 6 prépare des
cinq étonnant alors ça veut dire qu'il
veut on peut la jouer c'est ça
complètement aller 1 mais il prépare des
5es et défend à 5
mais il fait pas le truc pour simplifier
à fond pays-bas il veut pas la turbo
d'euros
je viens du coup
bah écoutes je sais pas s'ils jouent
bien mais ils jouent ils jouent une
partie du jeune et jolie joue que ça
joue quoi ils jouent une partie du jeu
d'échecs
chez moi ça me fait penser karpov une
finale deux tours bientôt deux mois
enfin il défend quoi puis avant l'autre
arrive pas et propose une offre s'en
fout il joue en fait on y voit qui va
jamais perdre moi je vais pas perdre
façon donc je joue ça ne l'étonné comme
anecdote mais je n'ai pas perdu oui j'ai
fait une petite nul quand même a
probablement mais bon ça fait suer
l'adversaire quoi la tunisie fait des
cinq ont fait nul bon j'ai pas moins
bien je fais ces six
mais ouais mais en fait notre impact
peut être moralement l'autre ouais c'est
comme hier machin que même quand quand
c'est égal en face aux ajouts
moment
n'empêche que tu as vu
lecture du langage corporel j'y
passerais s'est dit très serein et se
rabat et du coup ils jouent ces six
milles offerts ne peut pas faire mieux
mais n'est pas ça qu'il veut regrette
peut-être ne pas être entré dans le but
de faire h3
30 ans le truc est un
je dire ce que dit mon ordi après
après ces six
là grand chose
je réfléchis un petit peu je me dis ce
fut attaqué chez maje et d'amener un qui
m'attire mais bon
il est mal tourner cette histoire
va sûrement se prendre
des cinq là dessus
bon ajout mais personne n'est vraiment
mieux je pense
jouer une partie du jeu d'échecs
notamment
je crois c'est six länder travers de ce
que dit
il ya plus d'un plus qu'un coup un qui
fait 0-0 ici j'en ai déjà 3
on est tous voir enfin c'est pour ça
c'est dur de dire un cours particulier
on tour cédé 1 c'est une des options je
te ramène tour au centre
évidemment la dame des trois toujours
pareil tu tues tu enlèves de certains
trucs tu défends un peu ton foulée trois
distances
pourquoi pas après il y avait peut être
un coup si tu veut liquider faire nul
c'est le 5 s'est passé alors si tu te
sens un peu nerveux
puis enfin quand ils bouffent la dame
pour eux
tu fait qu'il prend 1,5 il prend b3 tu
prend b3
b4 guiniot 5 comme
ça je dis mal à te voir perdre quoi
agile nerveusement ça c'est si tu veux
plus de combats quoi je sais pas mais ok
donc là il a fait pousser 2
pourquoi pas il s'enlève l'animal du fou
au 6eme peut-être des 5es voilà c'est ce
que j'avais et cf bon faut changer
là-bas tu vas pas te prendre
ces ultra droite trop riche trop itx
visé
ça ne me fait pas peur
ouais c'est bourges avait annoncé sur
twitter une belle petite nul encore
espère
aller plus que année encore 11
ce que nous réclamons veulent et 14 nuls
en lisant rapport le cm1 14 ans on sera
très heureux
au moins arriver jusqu'à 6
je viens puis 7 me much
dit c'est possible ça me paraît
difficile maintenant à dépouiller
instable années paul n'y arrivera pas
alors il faudra t il aurait fallu un
caruana alors non ce serait bien qu ils
pouvaient d'un quota stable 6,14 il faut
changer le format bon française partie
peut-être 12h30 chacun tu sais
non mais déjà si on à cidre au pour
commencer c'est beau
mais bon 12-14 ce serait magnifique par
contre si on arrive à douche je pense
qu'on fait 14
oui
surtout que mes impôts doit pas se
sentir simone pour les rapides et carl
scène non plus avant dans la nuit sont
très bien donc ça peut être notre chance
en fait ça commence empiler les nuls
peut-être à la fin c'est foudrot d'euros
mais bon on n'y arrivera pas je pense
j'ai peur tous les jours the year
caruana il savait que nul ne pouvait pas
la dernière il a vraiment trop s'il
était vraiment mal c'est carlson
qu'inhibantes à songeons fous je fais nu
mais je te bornes rapides
moi je suis vraiment inquiète tous les
jours qui est une victoire
pour le moment ça tient mais
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je pense ça va tenir encore
après il y avait une idée de suite offs
qui d'ailleurs est de faire jouer les
matchs des partages avant le 1 800 m aux
bénéfices pour forcer une victoire un
moment donné dans le match s'est joué le
départage avant commencer par le
départage
belle idée oui
c'est sûr conseil qu'à travers
l'histoire quand le champion rester
champion ou des veinules c'est comme ça
et je le département il ya vraiment
jamais une nulle dans les matchs ça
n'avait vraiment jamais
niveau d'une igp rothstein nil et karpov
et kasparov
jamais quoi en fait
tout cas ça c'est une idée magnifique
directeur général de la fidh
ça se présente un petit peu monsieur
monsieur suite au ski
mais
non en fait c'est vrai que récemment il
ya eu beaucoup de matches nuls
depuis à toi cramique topalov avocat
nick leake au
kram ligue des champions on va vraiment
m'aider départage pour qu'ils me
voulaient plus jamais nous y voilà ça
commence dès 2006 krainik topalov niel
oui un an google phone nul
karl saine car il n'y a eu une quinzaine
caron daniel ça fait quatre en 15 ans
alors qu'avant c'était une fois tous les
cas ce que la proportion de nul a
tellement augmenté oui mais donc en fait
c'est pas de mètres avant les départage
après les départage des départagent pas
de départage c'est juste ça arrive c'est
tout enfin il faut pas inventer un truc
à mais le point ce que disait valls et
que les joueurs jouent tellement bien
c'est lui qui m'a fait avec ce virus et
que le niveau de jeu a tellement élevé
est tellement élevé aujourd'hui que pour
qui est du spectacle et on doit réduire
le temps pour avoir plus de fautes et
qui des vainqueurs parce que maintenant
elle après pas elle va trop loin enfin
là je sais pas si vous imaginez mais
servent que donc les noirs c'est les
joueurs qui défendent la prépa leva 15
jusqu'au 21e puis la peur et c'est parce
que les blancs on fait une photo qui
jouent et son premier couac arles scène
c'est ici dans la partie il peut déjà
faire nul ouais alors ils pouvaient
faire nul à la maison
sans avoir eu à jouer un seul coup par
lui même bon ça faut arriver mais
rarement
et avec moins de certitudes aussi parce
que tu avais pas l'ordi pour
double-échec même s'était bien amusé
comme un fou tu as confiance tentée
c'est cependant
une part d'incertitude il arrivait
d'ailleurs ah bah ça marchait pas marché
paraît d'ailleurs dans les faits la
vidéo avec les russes cov et
leers pas ce qui s'est passé
oui au restart
je sais pas si c'est vraiment ça mais ça
le devient de partout souvent it was
elle devient les gladiateurs c'était
quoi oui parce que c'est du sport je
sais pas mais en tout cas ils te mettent
ils te modifie les règles pour sa
spectaculaire genre le volet ils sont
libres fait chier les lettres choisies
on vas tu sers tu fais lettre ça compte
quand même
le foot fait plus de passes en retrait
au gardien tu mené au score tu fais pas
ce bruit que l'armée est la redonne des
bombes mais ça reste des jeux à chaque
fois c'est pour s'amuser de batterie
prend la professionnaliser donc on a un
peu dévoyé le truc énorme et même à la
base en fait cet effet pour s'amuser
tous les trucs été fait pour s'amuser
ouais vous pour amuser la galerie du
prêt des jeux
donc oui le but c'est pas juste soin du
spectacle mais faut
regarder ce à quoi m en vrai en plus le
rapide les joueurs enfin tu vois regard
sur chaise comme connecte-toi sur trois
points comme par exemple les gens ils
jouent soit en 3 + 0 sur 15 pouces 10,9
cm il n'y a jamais personne qui joue en
deux heures deux heures pour s'amuser en
fait
dans mes tubes pokora et maric mais on
peut aussi citer d'autres entraîneur
guardiola peut-être peut-être pas de
dire exactement la même chose n'est pas
de dire tu sais ce que tu as va au
cirque il veut bien jouer quoi j'aime ça
il faut bien jouer plein de gens qui
aiment bien jouer qui aiment que ce soit
spectaculaire qui aime qui débute
c'est peut-être son but marqué un but de
plus que l'adversaire plutôt que de lire
déjà je prend pas de but après
évidemment tu fais avec l'effectif que
tu as tu fait je sais il ya plein de
contraintes mais pablo correa sapad mon
pull été l'entraîneur j'ai cité ennuis
si je te parler de quelqu'un à quoi bon
entraîneur
ouais et puis même là pas même à jouer
c'est plus marrant en fait même pour les
joueurs c'est plus drôle
à vrai dire
mais en gros tout ça pour dire que
probablement que la cadence
aide à ce qu'il y ait autant de nuls
quoi
en voulant jouer en quoi il faut il faut
leur taf est il que les plans mis en
oeuvre on faire les joueurs il fait nuit
s'est vraiment bien sûr mais c'est dur
la pendule la
fédé 5 ça à faire le 5 normalement et le
faire reprendre mais ça me semble
logique
et après on juste pour revenir sur le
fait de changer des canes ans je sais
pas quoi en fait j'ai pas envie de
complètement tout changer il ya plein de
sports dans lesquels je tutoie attaché à
la tradition
et ses terrains je sais pas alors
parlons de tennis mais je sais pas je
suis pas trop ravi de
changer les 7 en quatre jeux gagnants
mais bon ils vont peut-être le faire
justement parce que il juge sa il ya
plein de sports ils ont pas peur de
changer le rugby je suis bien chaque
année puis nous voilà une qui ajustait
leur aiguille en fête sont vraiment et
voilà c'est un modèle et ça dénature pas
le jeu dont tu peux le faire mais
intelligente par petites touches tu peux
revenir cette étude avant s'est trompé
en fait non c'est pas grave on a droit
se tromper mais le rugby en fait
j'essaye vraiment changé les règles pour
garder l'esprit en fait ouais
c'est comme si tu avais 15 les équipes
sur les stratégies et que ça casse le
l'essence du truc
du coup je reviens il essaye de modifier
pour tous que ça reste un sport
d'évitement et que ça reste pas qu'un
sport de contact chaque année il
n'aimait pas du tout le c'est difficile
de lutter contre ça mais tu vois les
équipes qui envoyait que des gros
ça ils essayent d'éviter on va essayer
de garder quand même l'esprit du jeu
avec les changements de revendeurs
ils reprennent surtout beaucoup de
règles du 13 si on a des tamis treiziste
le chat est donc voilà je veux dire
qu'ils viennent des sports sérieux qui
arrive à gérer tout ça aux échecs on
pourrait essayer je dis pas qu'on va
forcément y du premier coup et comme je
dis on a le droit de se tromper une
petite erreur on modifie un peu et
machin on y arrive
mais c'est sûrement pas anodin comme je
vous dis qu'il ya déjà eu quatre matches
mais ondes qui fait nul sur l'ensemble
des partis même cinq matches par an
depuis 2004
a lieu qui me dit que lui pense que ce
serait une erreur monumentale et que le
problème des déchets qui sont bien plus
les ordis que les cadences mais il ya un
truc tu pourras jamais changé votre tard
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont là tu veux pas
supprimer toute la planète donc tu
essayes de jouer sur ce que tu peux
faire à l'époque n'est pas les ordi mais
c'est en fait ils sont là ils sont là
c'est fort je vais les ordis c'est un
fait que faire
si on va essayer de faire avec ce qu'on
peut faire
pourquoi presse jacques 960 vrai bon là
tu changes de jeu mais j'aime beaucoup
la chaîne 960 mais trop dur pour les
spectateurs ça c'est tous ces
spectateurs le problème moi j'ai jamais
joué en fait
mais là c'est quand même dingue très
violente où tu es tu change rien du tout
tout tout peut aussi rentrer avant d'en
arriver là de faire d'autres choses car
il faisait vraiment ça la dernière
solution
même si j'adorais jouer d'ailleurs même
je préférerais faire plus de 960 mois et
maurice il ya plein de tournois giral fr
dernier que j'avais fait à reykjavik il
ya trois ans
et voilà je devrais rejoint credixia pas
de restriction il refera l'année je
referais je serais très heureux en
1960 masque vrai
c'est kevin ça ne m'étonne pas qu'un tel
disent qu'ils aiment myrtille c'est
ce genre de joueurs préfèrent
chances que le même vote dans le plein
sens inverse mais il n'a jamais joué
j'aime beaucoup je t'ai jamais vu ça me
plaît
c'est kevin j'aime vraiment ce jeu
auquel je l'avais joué des maximes
lagarde mais j'aime je suis sûr qu'il
est forte et belle mais cinq jeux
lagarde qui est bien joué ce soir je
suis pas si les levées gagnait déjà très
possible qu'il ait gagné mais les trous
et qui joue bien j'ai perdu contre lui
mais bien perdu alors que j'avais battu
d'autres bons joueurs donc dans le
tournage fait des nuls j'ai perdu
d'autres mais je veux dire c'était pas
d'asile et bien d'un feeling pour le jeu
donc c'est donc là ça va partir sur 7
sur des échanges massif on est
allé voir mon avis ça va bouger vite on
va on va aller montrer à l'écran parce
que ça ça devrait jouer rapidement ça
devrait être un quelques coups à
peut-être pas si rapidement ça
bon il va le rendre à fléchir est
logique de faire des procès quatre quand
même
pour les tournois la victoire 2.1.1 je
sais pas j'aime pas ça en fait
c'est une idée un si long et c'est aussi
la victoire à trois points les mêmes
modèles qu'au foot 3.1.1 nuls 0 défaite
mais en fait ce que je veux dire c'est
que moi je veux pas lutter contre les
nuls en tant que nul ça va c'est pas
anormal du jeu parfois fait des biens du
fait des bonnes parties et l'un et
l'autre et puis ça finit nul après un
long combat et à tout donner et est
dégoûté car et qui joue un plot à côté
ils se prennent trois points ou enfin
il ya un trop gros écart en fait parce
que nul c'est normal on va dire et ça va
gagner c'est très bien bravo mais en
fait c'est pas par anti jeu qui les
joueurs formule souvent et là tu joues
tu fais une bonne partie à la sarre
aussi et lacées nul et c'est pas ça très
dommage de voir pénaliser ça
donc
voilà je serais plutôt content ce
émises en essayant fed mais ça va pas
changer grand chose il y avait tout
autant de nuls façon et du coup un mec
qui ne vais pas nier le temps a été de
gagner ou des fois ça revenait juste au
même ça dépendra donc fait qu'il est
souvent moi je m'en fou juste qui est
100% de même ça c'est beaucoup et ça
compte ça on peut lutter un petit peu
puis c'est pas que ça c'est qu'en fait
quand on accélère les cadences samantha
plus de parti qui gagne mais en plus
c'est plus sympa à regarder pour les
spectateurs c'est sympa
[Musique]
mais en fait moi j'ai rien contre la
nulle en tant que bonne partie de parts
et d'autres ça a défendu c'était un
accident c'est c'est la vie en fait
c'est comme si j'arrête le foot et qui
annulent moyenne ue qu il fait des bonds
000 2 000
pour un superbe coup franc de loin votre
fils majeur celui ci est forcément
non mais des fois de voir des trucs de
génie oui mais si gardien génie russie
ou défenseurs et génie à jenny et gagna
pas mute et donc 0 0 c'est pas forcément
passe à dix quoi tu peur des matches où
on peut dire nul 2-2 aussi fin et ça
fait nul aussi
un bon match bon match
voilà c'est comme ça quoi donc voilà je
veux pas interdire les nuls
ça arrive et c'est normal
mais en fait le truc c'est qu'on laisse
la même cadence qui a 150 ans
un peu moins peut-être mais peu importe
alors que c'est plus le même jeu
à l'époque après huit coups là vais
réfléchir sur hackett oui je vous
donnais marshall mer dim empêche qu est
ce que je fais ton bien vite des quatre
chiens la première réflexion ce 21e coût
pour les noirs et il connaît
l'évaluation de la position non à ses
incomparables en fait vraiment
incomparable dont on va dire a besoin de
moins de temps pour être disons à
conditions similaires carrément tu vas
prendre la décision un peu hâtive de
maths en vitrine il y en a qui gérons
bien ça donne moins bien passé voilà
ce que chacune à 20 ou nuls est possible
même en boxe il peut y voir nulle en
fait
mais gérard c'est le cas le plus
probable de loin or pâle en boxe a dit
qu'on voit tous les échanges vont vous
parler à l'instance pour ça qu'on était
parti un petit peu en discussion parce
que là il va y avoir égalité matérielle
et plus grand chose à faire ouais ont pu
recouper les noirs vers 15 heures
bassam en quoi changer un fou on va
prendre angers7
il va prononcer trois reprenons ces
trois il va prendre j'ai cette belle
égalité matérielle
et au mieux du mieux avec les blancs
malheur au mieux on va échanger tout ça
on a
pierre même finale tire ça c'est genre
dans un bon scénario on échange tout ça
c'est bon sert pour les blancs mais
c'est quand même complètement nul ne me
bon je ne peux conduire non mais pas
c'est juste pour rire le scénario de
rêve fait nul aussi
non mais c'est un bon ça tu as mon parti
c'est un truc que j'utilise way pour
arriver à lui et pour 10 rebonds se sont
rangés aucune chance je vais pas
épiloguer même si les blancs il joue
avec les noirs contre c'est ce que tu
peux à défendre je sais pas en quoi
rentrer et yahoo gmail à exclure même si
je suis moins bien il va peut-être
réussir à gagner ce pion en fait c'est
l'occasion de venir donc ça va
non
c'est normalement d'euros facile aurait
évidemment ils vont quand même réfléchir
à la karl ça ne va pas jouer tempo parce
que ben il a du temps et il veut pas
faire une erreur oui il a raison de
réfléchir il faut prendre son temps ça
sert à rien de
mettre à l'eau
des efforts des mois d'efforts de
préparation et des heures d'efforts dans
la partie pour restituer la prépa en une
erreur parce qu'au lieu de prendre trois
minutes pour jouer ajoute m pourquoi on
prend son temps on vérifie c'est bien
mais bon ça se met en danger on est en
route mais à vrai dire je pense que
c'est une jeune trois minutes + 30
secondes par coup il fait du lycée avec
les noirs oui
avec
netgem tube je veux revers subis a
certes à deux ça fait nul mais tu vivras
chaque but de muntari qui me va gagner
et c'est c'est pas comparable aux échecs
perdu ce préfixe mais dire la partie
d'hier par exemple c'est comme un no 2
en fait
ok alors qu'arles scène il envoie il se
prend un but en contre vianney peut-être
dix années à banon a partout donna karan
en effet quand même nul c'est est-ce
parce c'était pas bien dans la partie à
peu bien énorme au niveau de jeu mais il
ya eu nulle quand bear mais c'est pas
pour autant de personnages essaient de
gagner quoi ça veut dire
[Musique]
22.22 travers de deux crânes 2 crados
mais bon c'est cool
même si villarreal du betis séville 2 2
c'est sympathique simple sympathique
sympathique
du foot à 13 francs g7
peut-être qu'on fasse un petit à frêche
c'est la position qu'on avait on apprend
alors maintenant bon bah y'a plein de
coups on est le roi peut faire tourner
c'est pas le ft gijon
faites plutôt personnes voilà c'est pas
comme expliqué en fait trop sexy même
même même si le russe a gagné un de ses
deux pions pas tout échange et l'a donc
gagné un pion ce serait quand même nul
théorique parce que trois contre deux
avec des tours ça fait nul et il se
trouve que ça va pas être possible à
réaliser non plus
et quand on est un des rares victoires
en championnat du monde c'était la 10e
partie championnat 2016 lors d'une scène
sur cardiaque in
terris reparti pour karachi qui pouvait
forcer la d'euros en plus mais ils ont
changé les avatars des joueurs
s'étaient pas ces photos les autres
jours il en est des petits drapeaux
derrière wifi parce que nespouls drapeau
russe ou de son seuil et auteur
du milieu soit finalement le
commentateur norvégien il avait bien
essayé d'y annuler quasiment sans jouer
aujourd'hui
mais j'arrivais ben quoi on pouvait lire
ne garde
que ça me dérange avec trois trophées en
foot on va le juge habituellement je
vois pas trop l'intérêt je pense qu'au
foot de séoul gagné en fait
je sais pas si ça changerait beaucoup si
on refaisait les classements des
championnats avec lecteur de points ce
que seraient pas les mêmes que l'an
dernier ils n'auraient pas gagné parce
que par ailleurs la pagaille la plupart
du championnat depuis puis 2012
rappelons que cette fréquence même
résultat final car enfin santé serait un
peu mieux au classement cette année
basta verts ont très bien avec louis bah
ouais
ils ont bien joué aujourd'hui c'était
carton rouge
mérité non
il file au but et méthane a des airs sur
le
pas du tout chaque secteur
il est derrière il parlait pas il est
pas d'arrêt défenseur il ya faute au
début de l'action entre 100 et malibu le
père cette faute aliments pour s'envoler
vers le truc maintenant
et donc frustrant le but sur le coup
franc direct
et donc tu rentres à 1 à 10 3 0 non je
peux faire un sondage maintenant y'a
plus sur tarbes paris donc c'est un faux
truc
supporters de sainté aussi beaucoup
d'anti parisien aussi beaucoup moins sur
terre sainte et surtout est ce que les
gens ont vu le match c'est bon si l'ont
pas vu toi tu m'as ils vont voter ce que
ceux qui ont vu que j'ai pas vu je m'en
fous faudrait mettre un troisième nom
mais cette façon il ya les réussis pas
comme twitter voilà pour le mans et plus
de gens qui disent non vas tu vois
seshoka
existe
une homélie en fait il va intercepter il
veut pas te défoncer le mec est par
contre rennes et marseille blessé pas de
chance pour lui
dire ses patients en attente a pour le
coup j'ai pas aimé le tacle sur neymar
près à mi temps ou du coup il s'est pas
blessé dessus mais j'étais pas content
du tout du geste du stéphanois pour le
coup alors j'ai twitté il faut y aurait
pu voir rouge là dessus ça ne m'aurait
pas choqué on assure le rouge qui a eu
du jeu mais franchement non et ah oui en
fait il s'est blessé en sautant à
retombant sur la jambe du mec et
j'espère c'est pas trop grave pour lui
aussi dit j'ai pas vu mes roues jamais
arrêté même suspension de dix matches je
pense la sarthe c'est complètement égal
en fait je leur ai expliqué mais même si
tu échanges tout ça donc que tu gagnes
un pion la finale avec tour contre deux
pions
celle-là
contrat il est complètement nul ouais
enfin scénario si vous voulez
même dur à réaliser laférois réforme a
fondé sa battue
on me voit fait autour des 3 tours 5 400
tours des noirs 1 on fait n'importe quoi
mais on va la rendre après
comme à 4 exprès voilà il mesure qu'on
arrive à ça on rêve nul quand même
facile comme hier et il n'y a aucune
raison pour perdre un pion
quelqu'un qui dit qu'ils aient lyonnais
qu'il ait voulu me faire plaisent non
mais si la roja où je vais pas demander
à un arbitre en fait mais c'est juste
mon ressenti aujourd'hui j'ai voté non
en
fait c'est comme tu dis c'est plus et
qui sont pour paris
le seul truc
non mais sérieux enfin me dire que je
vous dis et cissokho il sera en rouge
sur son gros tacle en permutant
belgrade il est débile quoi mais
pourquoi pas mais là en fait
un club d'échecs m'arrêter là car à
saint-etienne
donc tu n'as pas le choix en fait après
y en a dans le coin je pense qu'un club
à saint chamond honte à
saint-just-saint-rambert temps d'un
break sur loire donc tu peux chercher
dans le coin mais à sant yann même je
pense t-on à coeur
gens qui sont comme moi avec sissoko je
suis d'accord avec la faim symbolique je
pense enfin là je donne vraiment on a
bien fait
jusqu'à sa charmante empêche je suis
quand même de saint-etienne de base que
j'ai passé 35 ans ou quoi bush
connaissent les lieux qui à 10 km de
chez moi quoi
tchèque dans le gard à nîmes je tourne a
sûrement d'autres façons vous regardez
même sur le site de la fédé
vous fait un petit google club d'échecs
tu tapes long de ta ville et puis tu
saura s'il ya ou pas
baltik par le stéphanois avec un beau
fouilla
si je mets à sa mère sur l'enfant à
rabat oui bien sûr
si halo rouge a gagné quand même ouais
mais deux fois voire 50 à 2 43 avec
prépondérante de supporters du psg donc
en fait sur un objectif très clairement
ya pas rouge quoi je
n'y a pas la vidéo
non en fait la vidéo et l'internet ou
six erreurs manifestes de l'arbitré en
fait tu peux pas dire que c'est un
scandale l'armée rouge je suis d'accord
c'est parce qu'on me l'a remis au juge
aurait vraiment pas ni moins
bon
combien bien sécurisé plein de manières
je pense pas qu'il ya une faute là tout
ce qu'on peut attendre c'est une erreur
de magnus plutôt parce que c'est vrai
que c'est plus magnus qui pourrait faire
une faute mais bon
tu auras beltoise il a joué mon cou très
bien refaire tomber en face non
bien sûr
cette la finale de mai la finale faut
les connaître
pour bien essayé la finale de fou
qui doit faire bien nul
on admire structures etc les blancs mais
le roi n'en l'a tellement actif c'est un
bon point pour les noirs et on peut pas
trop chrétiens ont passé on peut pas
passer que le roi
j'ose pas rêver qui fut professeur je
regarde pas le foot en fait ça
m'intéresse plus donc
juste avec pas parce qu'on a vu l'action
mais sinon je regarde pas quoi
c'est la partie
ce qu'ils ont fait
très vite mais ça en temps cette finale
elle doit annuler mais bon c'est
peut-être la meilleure chance pour les
blancs
enfin ils cherchent pas mort tu feras
dirt 3 il veut tenter f k trois des
quatre
hommes je crois qu'ils cherchent en fait
il y aurait pas là une 40e coup je
propose
non non
paris 9
0 espoir et manille dans un sens et dans
l'autre une histoire de pub quand même à
ça fait plaisir
tout cas très belle troisième partie
fabas là qu'on est en train de vivre
ensemble c'est vraiment un magnifique
combat espérons que ça continue sur la
même sur la même lancée à partir de
maintenant qu'on est une belle quatrième
partie mardi
le bol du même acabit
ça fait quand même plaisir ouais mais
bon
ça va être dur de maintenir le cap
c'est à vous de 30 ou 40 ont proposé que
l'on peut proposer nul c'est à partir du
40e coup sans avoir lu 40 1 c'est le cas
j'en suis sûr
magnifique
colonne
pour combler le vide de demain à demain
il ya le speech s
est très bien combler à tomber vite
demain 19h sur surtout jusqu'à
maintenant oui madame en australie du
savant très bien et où il devait durer
deux heures là je pense qu'il a pas
grand chose à raconter un peut-être
qu'une heure suffira je sais pas je lui
demanderais combien de temps tu penses
faut faire mais
qu'est ce que je veux dire ouais demain
19h sur cette même chaîne mv elle compte
caruana speech s voilà
bon en somme vesle favori a largement à
mon avis tu pas combien les robots m
pour une nouvelle
c'est un format qui lui convient mieux
car on a clairement
donc le vainqueur de ce match se jouera
le 9 pour une autre voie et de repos
j'étais super toute la vente que je
t'annonce et c'était ça à partir de là
tout a annoncé la game
non je suis content
banon message urgent a annoncé quand
même huit coups d'affilée
je suis très dur c'était qu'il faut sa
grosseur ce fauteuil d'ailleurs
ah non mais ouais c'est une petite
fierté personnes non mais bien sûr
paco rabanne est quoi
désolé j'étais coupé je suis aujourd'hui
voilà oui je pense de suite chasse mais
on s'en fout aussi en fait
ça tombe très bien dans
le match
et fut témoin ip en fait c'est ça ta pas
le match surtout en même temps combien
t'échauffer bien suivre elle a donc et
donc oui demain
demain 19h et puis à d'autres matches
après je sais pas trop le calendrier
vous pourrez retrouver
avec le projet lgv elle y anime sur ça
sera les 9 voilà il ya d'autres matches
avant il ya des bons joueurs qui jouent
vente a dû sauter d'une a4 d'ordures à
porte mais j'en sais rien
et je vois qu'ils sont faits deux
joueurs sont fait éliminer à cause de la
connexion
est aux chaunois d'europe 1 il pleut pas
qu'il a perdu contre saint guy tout cas
ils pouvaient pas cliqué stérile de
pouvoir cliquer quoi savoir clic
quand on ne l'attend
ajouté mme
penchard dans le contenu c'était bien
c'était propre c'était propre
c'est pas spectaculaire mais c'est pas
le problème là c'est juste ça joue bien
aujourd'hui lundi enfin ces prépas ses
21 coups d'ordi pour les noirs 1 et
c'est fini avait composé les premiers
jours c'était pas ouf c'était pas ouf
hier moi ce parti bah désolé en fait on
dit ce qu'on pense hélas là c'est parti
là aujourd'hui ça joue bien sûr joue
bien et nul
fait plaisir ouais enfin une bonne bonne
belle bonne preuve première partie
première bonne partie dans ce match sans
avoir fait match sans génie ni de l'un
ni de l'autre
d'ailleurs je pense si on regarde leur
cap mais le canard je suis assez sûr
qu'il va être assez levé sur ce drame et
oui
c'était une après au niveau du spectacle
absolument zéro intérêt mais ça c'est un
autre problème oui oui mesdames ou bien
meilleur ça c'est pas le problème des
joueurs ils ont bien joué ils ont fait
leur taf maison des jeunes juste je
regarde ça je regarde rien
c'est pareil mais dix joueurs ont super
bien gênant mais c'est hors trois là
c'est notre hall des joueurs ont été
très bons
youssef iii
l'impression qu'on est encore en
préparation là on est plus dans la prépa
en fait il a fait une feinte
favori il a même préparé sans se
rappeler comme maggie j'aurai fini le
pareil en fait oui il a fait exactement
la même partie je suis fan n'a pas la
même très pas merci le problème c'est le
problème mais si fava la même ferez pas
il fait la même il ya aucun souci
championnat un mois précoce est
intéressant pour moi de prépa
intéressant bas fait sacrément de prépa
mais après pour la challenger ce
fait c'est tellement un boulot de nos
candidats une pression aussi mental tu
te qualifies tape quand même un peu
besoin de souffler quoi donc ça
favorisera le champion surtout
mais du coup y'a plus de victoires ouais
challenge offre est à bout de souffle
serait crever seraient des fonds soient
des forfaits
y aura moins le nul
ce qui fait plaisir
les petites nul font toujours plaisir
fab
après ce qu'on pourrait faire c'est
carrément le champion fait les candidats
et puis il y en a une champions en fait
c'est bon sens avait été faite sur un
clin d'oeil je
répète que je fais c'est cette
[Rires]
magnifique
plaisir
bayard
2007 je pense
magnifique
bon va répéter fab du coup demain ne
venait pas 13 heures à 19 heures le
speech s avant pour nostra vaduz vous
pouvez retrouver les infos et sur mon
twitter
en jour et l'heure avec la ddt quand on
aura décidé je vous mettrai ça
tiendrait il faut surtout que je viens
du monde au format coupe du monde donc
un long cycle pour trouver un challenger
vient d'affronter viennent affronter le
champion il est fidèle au fisc pour la
finale alors il y avait en fait ce
format là genre en 98
[Musique]
suffit
ouais bah non en fait ils jouent pendant
un mois quasiment la coupe ils gagnent
ils arrivent au bout montée d un car
postal tout frais bon ils font des nuls
2 nuls en partie lente et puis après ça
joue en départage machin karpov arrive à
gagner contre un ordre à bout de est en
fait le champion c'est un trop gros
avantage en fin et il
faut laisser un peu de temps pour
souffler mais qui à l'époque à nantes
était vraiment fort car profond plus
karpov on va dire à partir de 90 étaient
moins ça alors il a eu son baroud
d'honneur et 80 monstrueux à linas 94 et
mais je veux dire ils étaient moins
forts kasparov ont ça c'est clair mais
même que dans deux chroniques ou que
d'autres
donc ouais c'est pas forcément non plus
j'ai l'impression que ce n'est pas au
moment de faire flamber 5 après un
certain temps avant de faire de le faire
je pense qu'il applique la stratégie de
son équipe plutôt que de jouer ce qu'ils
pensent unis le plus de chance ouais
mais c'est sûr qu'ils après je passe sur
fable qui décident sur l'échiquier
calais où il va jouer en fait ah non
mais c'est avant oui mais
non aurait dépôt par contre il forcément
on accorde enfin il y tout ce qu'on lui
dit mais sinon vous faites chez votre
espagnol josé autre chose il fera autre
chose
quand même lui qui joue
non juste y
ont de façon le temps il leur en reste
regardez là il en reste encore 37
minutes la partie déjà filtré belle
lurette il aurait pu jouer
et même coup il lui resterait 1h10 1
et clairement là
il ya blocus a aucun des joueurs ne peut
ne peut pas faire les rois sont bloqués
tout est bloqué
on peut le faire ça c'est bon
mais on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas de
beaux cadeaux et lahonce et enduro f6 re
re 5
cette affaire j'ai trois au nom 5 j'en
prends vraiment beaucoup trop leurs airs
j'ai quattro
nous sommes beaucoup plus forts at en
effet rudge
a été figé et 3,5 g 4
je suis là
en tout cas sur czech comme 30 secondes
chacun je la joue je clic vous aide à
faire tomber pas ah bah oui
bah bravo dépôt aurait coûté très
profond très fin ça fait plaisir ouais a
visé la nulle alors on est très heureux
je pense
d'ailleurs les fines fleurs
à la vie
il a sorti une boîte tout le monde peut
être rapide regard vide regarderont très
bien beaucoup mieux que j'ai envie de
synthés psg en tout cas un magnifique
très mal parti aujourd'hui fab le était
au rendez vous bonjour voila joué que
des bons coups partie parfaite une nulle
à une eu l'agréable finalement
c'est cool on vous fera le résumé voilà
je voulais une peu de films une petit
tube qui comptera pas du comes santa
claus i'll ans au moins
mais ça fait toujours ça de gagné ça de
gagné pour les gens quoi
voilà bon vous dis
à demain pour le speech s et après
demain pour la partie niro kahn de ce
match a le temps
merci à toi femme et demain les gars